Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt von der Metaebene in Unterstützung vom Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Jetzt gab es mal wieder eine kleine Pause und wir steigen wieder ein und greifen mal eine Themenlandschaft auf, die ehrlich gesagt hier bisher bei Raumzeit noch etwas unterrepräsentiert war bzw. eher am Rande der Besprechung von Missionen und anderen wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen immer mal wieder eine Rolle gespielt hat. Nämlich das große Ganze, die Kosmologie bzw. die Frage nach der Struktur des Universums und sozusagen dem Zusammenhalt von allem. Viel haben wir hier schon geschaut auf Details unseres Sonnensystems. Nur so der Blick hinaus war bestenfalls in Sendungen wie über die extrasolaren Planeten vertreten, ein bisschen auch schon beim Alpha-Magnet-Spektrometer, wo diese Fragen aufkamen, wo auch schon das erste Mal fallen gelassen wurde, dass ja seit einiger Zeit alles anders ist. Und wie anders das jetzt alles ist, das möchte ich gerne mal besprechen und Galaxien und Kosmologie ins Auge fassen. Und dazu begrüße ich Markus, Markus Brüggen.
Hallo.
Markus, du bist Wissenschaftler an der Hamburger Sternwarte in Bergedorf, wo ja noch ein paar schöne alte Teleskope rumstehen, aber die nicht das Zentrum des Ganzen sind.
Genau, die Hamburger Sternwarte, die ist älter als die Uni Hamburg, gehört mittlerweile aber zur Uni Hamburg und die gibt es seit mehr als 100 Jahren. Ursprünglich wurde sie gegründet und war dann am Millantor im Zentrum von Hamburg. Und nach relativ kurzer Zeit wurde dann klar, dass es im Zentrum von Hamburg nicht so gut war, Teleskope zu betreiben, weil auch da die Lichtverschmutzung und die Luftverschmutzung schnell schlimm genug wurden. Dann ist man auf den einzigen Berg gezogen, den es in der Nähe gab, und das ist der Goyenberg in Hamburg Bergedorf. Also ein Berg ist natürlich ein bisschen lächerlich, der ist irgendwie 30 Meter hoch oder so, aber das ist draußen in Hamburg mehr oder weniger nicht drin. Und dort steht dann die Sternwarte auch heute noch. Wie du gesagt hast, stehen da noch viele Teleskope, die aus allen möglichen Zeiten, ein ganz großer Refractor zum Beispiel und ein neu sanierter 1-Meter Zeisspiegel. All diese Teleskope werden allerdings nicht mehr benutzt für die aktive Forschung. Mit der Ausnahme von einem Teleskop, das ist ein Teleskop, das noch für verschiedene Projekte in der Exoplanetforschung benutzt wird, hauptsächlich für Studentenprojekte, aber sonst beobachten wir da draußen eigentlich nicht mehr. Eine Ausnahme ist die Radiostronomie. Für die Radiostronomie ist das Wetter egal und ist auch die Höhe egal. Und da haben wir ein neues Teleskop gebaut vor anderthalb Jahren in Norderstedt, im Norden von Hamburg. Das ist das Low-Frequency-Array, das ist so ein Radioteleskop, da kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal zu. Und das ist ein Teil eines europäischen Radioteleskops und von dem beobachten wir aktiv dann auch in Hamburg aus noch.
Bevor wir vielleicht noch mehr auf die Astronomie als solche und auch vielleicht die Sternweite nochmal im Detail kommen, wird mich interessieren, wie bist du denn eigentlich in dieses Feld geraten? Also du hast ja dann auch sicherlich irgendwann mal so einen Erweckungsmoment gehabt haben in deinem Leben. Wie früh war der?
Ja, das kann ich wirklich nicht genau sagen, ob es einen Moment gab. Also ich kann mich an keinen einzelnen Moment erinnern. Also nicht irgendwie so was, wo meine Eltern mir, nicht die Mondlandung, ne, und auch nicht, dass meine Eltern mir irgendwo ein Teleskop gekauft haben, wo ich zum ersten Mal in einem Planetarium war. Ich glaube, mich hat schon immer Naturwissenschaft und Mathematik interessiert. Und ja, ich kann mich nicht an eine Zeit erinnern, wo ich mich nicht für Naturwissenschaft interessiert habe. Auf irgendeine Art und Weise.
Ja, na gut, aber dann muss ja dann irgendwann diese Richtung dann auch sich abgezeichnet haben.
Genau. Also ich hab Physik studiert.
Hätte ja auch Biologe werden können oder so.
Genau, das sieht recht früh aus, weil ich mir schlecht Sachen merken kann. Das wird man wahrscheinlich auch noch innerhalb dieser Podcasts merken. Ich kann mir sehr schlecht Sachen merken und das ist für Biologie schlecht. Und deswegen fällt das aus. Ja, letztendlich blieb da nur Physik übrig, weil da man sich relativ wenig merken muss. Und ich hab dann Physik studiert. Und da innerhalb der Physik, da hab ich mich dann auch erst während des Studiums dann dazu entschieden, Astronomie zu machen. Andere Sachen der Physik haben mich auch interessiert.
Aber man sieht nicht so viele Sachen merken.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Man muss relativ wenig merken.
Weil man immer alles nachschlagen kann.
Man kann alles nachschlagen natürlich, das könnte man jetzt für die Biologie auch sagen. Aber es geht ja eigentlich nicht darum, sich Sachen zu merken oder Sachen zu wissen, sondern es geht ja eigentlich darum, Sachen zu verstehen. Und solche Theorien zu verstehen. Wenn man jetzt mal eine explikative Theorie, allgemeine Relativitätstheorie, dazu muss man sich jetzt nicht viel merken. Man muss verstehen, wie das funktioniert. Und dann gibt es dann zwei, drei Gleichungen. Und damit reicht der Rest, muss man davon heraus herleiten. Da muss man nicht viel wissen. Also eigentlich alles ganz einfach? Einfach im Sinne von, dass man sich nicht viel merken muss. Allerdings sind die ganzen Zusammenhänge teilweise kompliziert. Und man muss sich da reinfuchsen, aber das ist was anderes.
Das heißt, du hast dich dann für ein Physikstudium entschieden. Und das mündete dann in die Beschäftigung mit der Astronomie. Jetzt hast du ja schon beschrieben, Hamburger Sternwarte ist halt eine relativ alte und ehrwürdige Einrichtung. Ich hatte auch neulich meine Führung, war sehr hübsch. Auch diese ganzen alten Refraktoren und sonstigen Installationen, ich weiß nicht wie viele Einzel-Teleskopen stehen da oben, so 5, 6, so eine Größenordnung. Genau, das war sehr beeindruckend, aber es ist ja jetzt sozusagen nicht state of the art. Also das war es alles mal zu seiner Zeit, aber wie du schon angesprochen hast, so Hamburg ist eigentlich viel zu hell, von dort nennenswerte Beobachtungen zu machen, da geht man jetzt schon lieber nach Chile und schaut durch die nicht vorhandenen Wolken. Aber dieses Low Frequency Array, was du angesprochen hattest, das ist jetzt so ein neues Ding, was solche Probleme in gewisser Hinsicht umgehen kann?
Genau. Also diese Sachen, die bei uns auf dem Campus in Bergedorf stehen, die haben eher einen musealen Charakter. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz schön krass, sich mal vor Augen zu führen, wie schnell sich eben dieses Feld und die Technologie verändert haben. Das eben Sachen, die vor ein paar Jahrzehnten state of the art waren, wo da Forschung an der Grenze gemacht wurde, dass das ein paar Jahre später schon einfach nur ein Fall fürs Museum ist. Und dass sich das so schnell verändert und man damit gar nichts mehr reißen kann. Und so schnell verändert sich das. Und ja, die Radioastronomie ist ein relativ junges Feld, verglichen zum Beispiel mit der optischen Astronomie, die es schon ganz, ganz lange gab. Die Menschen haben für Jahrhunderte lang den Himmel im optischen Bereich beobachtet. Erst in den 30er Jahren, im Grunde erst nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, haben die Leute begonnen, mit Radioantennen den Himmel abzutasten, zu beobachten.
Also mit höheren Frequenzbereichen zu arbeiten?
In niedrigen Frequenzbereichen, in längeren Wellenlängen. Wir haben lange Zeit die Leute in Wellenlängen beobachtet, die ein paar Zentimeter lang sind, also Gigahertz-Frequenzen, die man sich da anschaut. Die haben verschiedene Vorteile und verschiedene Nachteile. Ein Vorteil ist zum Beispiel, dass das Wetter scheißegal ist. Die Wellen gehen durch die Wolken durch. Der Nachteil ist, dass die Teleskope größer werden müssen. Denn um ein Bild zu bekommen, das genauso scharf ist, muss man eben ein Teleskop haben, das eben genauso groß ist, ausgedrückt in Wellenlängen. Wie wenn man es im optischen Bereich macht. Wenn die Wellenlänge größer ist, muss dementsprechend das Teleskop auch größer werden. Und da braucht man eben so riesen Schüsseln, die man dann aufbaut.
Das Ding, was jetzt gerade in China frisch eröffnet wurde, das 500-Meter-Teleskop.
Genau, gestern glaub ich. Da hat man eben diese riesen Schüsseln, die man sich da anschauen muss, um eben Bilder mit vergleichbarer Schärfe zu erzeugen. Aber das Wetter ist egal. Das ist natürlich nicht der Hauptgrund, warum man im Radiobereich beobachtet. Im Radiobereich sieht man eben einen anderen Aspekt, der Himmelsobjekt. Man sieht ganz andere Sachen. Galaxien zum Beispiel sehen im Radiobereich ganz anders aus. Man sieht zum Beispiel keine Sterne im Radiobereich. Schwach nur Sterne sind jetzt nicht das, was hauptsächlich im Radiobereich leuchtet. Man sieht andere Sachen, höhere energetische Phänomene. Das ist in einem Gebiet, das wir in Hamburg verfolgen, dass wir jetzt den Himmel beobachten im Radiobereich bei Wellenlängen, die noch länger sind. Also der niedrig frequente oder langwellige Radiobereich, wo die Wellenlängen mehrere Meter sind. Das haben wir bis jetzt noch nie gemacht. Der Grund dafür ist, dass es besonders schwierig ist, weil die Beteilsgruppe noch größer sein müssen. Man kann jetzt keine Schüssel bauen.
Welcher konkrete Frequenzbereich ist das jetzt?
Das ist der Frequenzbereich zwischen 30 MHz und 240 MHz. Also genau oben das UKW-Radio herum. Dieser Frequenzbereich hat man bis jetzt ausgespart, weil die Schüsseln, die man dafür bräuchte, wären noch größer, um vernünftige Bilder zu bekommen. Da bräuchte man Schüsseln, die hundertte Kilometer groß sind. Und das kann man natürlich nicht bauen. Also nimmt man da einen Trick an. Der Trick ist, man nimmt ganz viele Antennen, verteilt über ganz Europa und simuliert dann eine Schüssel, die so groß ist wie ganz Westeuropa. Indem man eben, wenn man in eine gewisse Richtung schaut, die zwischen den ganzen Antennen im Grunde so etwas wie Zeitverschiebung einbaut. Das, wenn man irgendwie jetzt nach, in eine Richtung schaut, das, dann kommen die Wellen ja erst bei einer Station an und mit einer gewissen Zeitverzögerung bei der Station, die 100 Kilometer weiter entfernt ist, an. Auf der Erde. Und wenn man da Zeitverschiebung einbaut, digital am Computer in Nachbearbeitung, dann ist der virtuelle Sichtstrahl dieses Antennen-Arrays auf diese Quelle ausgerichtet. Und so kann man das Teleskop fokussieren, auch wenn man keine Schüssel hat, die die Wellen fokussieren und die man irgendeiner Quelle nachführt. Und das nennt man Phasen-Array. Und das ist eine neue Technologie, die im Grunde jetzt erst möglich geworden ist durch die Anwendung von extremst leistungsfähigen Computern. Und deswegen haben wir dieses Teleskop gebaut. Das sind über 100.000 Antennen, die zwischen Polen und im Grunde den Niederlanden von Süddeutschland hoch bis nach England und Schweden verteilt sind auf so Fußballfeldgroßen Feldern. Und diese sind mit 10 Gigabit pro Sekunde verbunden, gehen in einen Zentralrechner in die Niederlanden. Und das generiert dann ein Bild fast des gesamten Himmels. Die ganze Zeit.
Wie viele Antennen sind das insgesamt?
Mehr als 100.000.
Mehr als 100.000?
Ja, mehr als 100.000 Antennen.
Die für sich genommen aber nicht ein Fußballfeldgroß sind?
Nein, die sind aufgebaut an Stationen. Jede Station ist ungefähr so ein Fußballfeldgroßes Ding und darauf stehen mehrere 100 Antennen. Dann gibt es wieder, davon gibt es insgesamt 50 solcher Fußballfelder und auf diesen 50 Stationen zusammengenommen sind die 100.000 Antennen.
Okay, also 50 Orte, an denen viele kleine Antennen zusammengefasst sind. Ich dachte ja, 100.000 Fußballfelder, dann würde ja der Sport leiden.
Ja, da würde auch einiges anderes leiden. Und damit kann man sich den Himmel anschauen. Und das ist irgendwie ein Technologie-Projekt, das wir jetzt im Grunde gerade erst fertiggestellt haben. Und damit schaut man jetzt, dadurch kann man eben den Himmel mit enorm hoher Auflösung in einem völlig unbekannten Wellenlängenbereich abscannen und wir hoffen und haben auch schon neue Sachen gefunden, von denen man überhaupt gar nicht wusste, dass es sowas gibt.
Unbekannt im Sinne von, das wurde so in der Form noch nicht getan. Also man hat sich diesen Wellenbereich eigentlich noch gar nicht angeschaut. Auch nicht bei Missionen außerhalb der Atmosphäre.
Genau. Das ist dann eine Sache, wenn man danach über Raumfahrt und über Zukunftsprojekte spricht, was dann auch eine Weiterentwicklung ist. Denn es gibt ein anderes Problem bei diesen Wellenlängen, ist, dass der Oberteil der Atmosphäre, die Ionosphäre, die Signale verzerrt. Und deswegen muss man mit dem Computer das nach bearbeiten, um diese Verzerrung wieder rückgängig zu machen.
Also die Atmosphäre rausrechnen, sozusagen.
Die Atmosphäre rausrechnen, genau.
Und was ist mit UKW? Ich meine, das funkt auch noch ganz freudig dazu.
Genau. Das ist das andere Problem. Die menschengemachte Strahlung. Deswegen sind Radioteleskope meistens in irgendwelchen Vulkankratern drin. Zum Beispiel auch das 500-Meter-Teleskop, die Chinesen ist in irgendeinem Tal drin. Also auch in Effelsberg, das Teleskop in der Vulkan-Eifel.
Oder auf Puerto Rico.
Genau, die sind meistens irgendwo drin, um einfach die menschengemachten Störquellen auszuhalten. Deswegen sind die meisten unten, während die meisten optischen Teleskope irgendwo auf einem Berg stehen, sind die meisten unten. Das haben wir jetzt auch nicht, aber dieses Teleskop befindet sich in einem, der mit Elektros- oder Radiusmog dicht gedrängt ist in Regionen der Welt in Westeuropa. Aber das ist auch dank der Computer, kann man das alles rausfiltern. Diese Empfänger haben ganz viele Kanäle drin, und die Computer rechnen die Sachen heraus, was da ein Störquell dran ist. Zum Beispiel das UKW-Band wird ganz ausgefiltert, aber es gibt auch viele andere Störquellen. Und das ist auch immer wieder ein Kampf. Im Moment kämpfen wir da zum Beispiel mit den digitalen Audiosendern und allen möglichen Sachen, aber das wird jetzt so weit. Aber man kann das machen, das funktioniert sehr gut. Wer bei noch niedrigeren Frequenzen geht, zu noch längeren Wellenlängen, dann kommen die Wellen gar nicht mehr durch. Das weiß man ja zum Beispiel, dass wir zum Beispiel beim Kurzwellenradio auch argentinische Stationen hören können, weil die Wellen, die Radiowellen von Eden dann an der Ionosphäre reflektiert werden und dann um den ganzen Erdball gehen und andersrum die Wellen von draußen auch nicht mehr durchkommen. Und wenn man zu noch niedrigeren Wellenlängen gehen möchte, dann müsste man ins Weltall gehen. Und da gibt es Pläne, auf dem Mond eine Station zu machen.
Weil er ja keine Atmosphäre hat.
Da fällt das weg. Der hat keine Ionosphäre und da könnte man das dann hinlegen und diese Teleskope sind eigentlich extrem primitiv. Die sind komplex, weil die ganze Computertechnologie und die ganze Software dahinter aufwendig ist. Aber die Hardware ist total billig. Es sind im Grunde nur Kabel, die man auf den Boden schmeißt. Und dann wird das nur per Software ausgerichtet und verarbeitet. Das ist eigentlich das Geile an dieser ganzen Technik.
Aber wenn man das jetzt auf dem Mond macht, müsste man dann den Computer dafür auch noch mit auf den Mond machen, damit das auch schnell genug ausgewertet werden kann. Weil man will ja nicht die Rohdaten vom Mond schicken zum Gigabit und so. Das dürfte schwierig werden, auch mit Laser. Das ist wahrscheinlich knifflig.
Genau.
Das wäre dann das Problem, man müsste sozusagen so einen Hochleistungscomputer auf dem Mond betreiben.
Genau, und dafür musste man natürlich auch dann die entsprechende Energie dann da zur Verfügung haben. Das ist immer ein bisschen ein Problem. Sondern weil es nur wenige Stellen auf dem Mond gibt, die eben die ganze Zeit Sonne haben. Die meisten Stellen auf dem Mond haben ja dann eben fast zwei Wochen Dunkelheit. Und deswegen ist es auch mit Solar-Energie schwierig. Naja, das ist alles noch reine Zukunftsmusik. Aber das wäre dann die Konsequenz, wenn man zu noch niedrigeren Frequenzen gehen möchte, dass man das dort macht. Und da gibt es Leute, die darüber nachdenken. Über Laserlinks, mit ein bisschen Computer-Hardware da oben, an Stellen, die immer Sonne haben. Da ist eine Kraterrende. Da gibt es in der Nähe der Pole-Region, wo man das machen kann. Solche Themen gibt es.
Aber das LFA ist schon in Betrieb?
Das LFA gibt es seit vier Jahren. Mittlerweile fängt es erst im letzten Jahr an, Bilder zu polizieren, so wie es gedacht oder gewünscht war.
Wir sind noch in der Kalibrierungs- und Findungsphase.
So ein bisschen.
Wie das auch bei anderen Missionen ist.
Es dauert eine Weile, bis es wirklich gut funktioniert.
Man muss sich mit Teten ausrecken und gucken, wie das so ist. Und dann abstimmen auf die Realität. Was sind so die Erwartungen, in was man da reinschauen kann? Also bisher war es ja immer so, in dem Moment, wo so ein neues Frequenz-Fass geöffnet wurde, Röntgen-Astronomie, Gamma-Strahlen, Beobachtung etc., hat man ja immer wieder ganz neue Phänomene gesehen. Also Dinge, die so vorher überhaupt noch sich gar nicht abgebildet haben. Infrarot, wenn wir sicherlich auch nochmal drüber sprechen, ähnlich. Gibt es hier eine Erwartungshaltung, was einem da auf einmal sich entgegenrecken könnte?
Ja, man weiß, und man denkt zumindest, dass man weiß, was man da so sehen würde von den Ganzen. Wir verstehen ja viele physikalische Prozesse von Galaxien und sonst was. Und da kann man sich ja vorstellen so ein bisschen, was man entdeckt. Also das weiß man. Zum Beispiel Synchrotron-Strahlung, das ist bestimmte Radiostrahlung entdeckt, die von extrem schnellen und relativistischen Teilchen in Magnetfeldern produziert werden. Dass man Pulsare trifft, Neutronensterne, die ganz schnell rotieren. Viele Sachen, da hat man ganz konkrete, ganz klare und auch ganz genaue Erwartungen, was man da sieht. Und andere Sachen. Und das ist eigentlich das Spannendere fast. Dass man immer hofft, dass es irgendetwas gibt, was man überhaupt nicht erwartet. So ist es glaube ich immer, wenn man so in eine neue Region vorstößt, dass man hofft, dass man irgendwas sieht, was kein Mensch erwartet hätte. Aber gleichzeitig weiß man, dass es auch viele interessante Sachen gibt, die man studiert und die man testet, wo man im Grunde weiß, wonach man sucht.
Jetzt wollen wir ja mal so ein bisschen den Blick nach außen wagen. Also die Astronomie liefert da einen Teil der Informationen. Andere Informationen werden ja auch von Deep Space Missionen geliefert. Allerdings hat sich ja die Erforschung des Weltalls zu Beginn natürlich erstmal so um den Umkreis der Erde, dann war der Mond natürlich ein heißes Thema, dann hat man es halt geschafft auch planetare Missionen zu machen. Vor allem die Voyager-Missionen, die glaube ich insofern zumindest für mich persönlich immer eine der bemerkenswertesten Missionen überhaupt ist, weil die gefühlt so ein bisschen eigentlich noch vor ihrer Zeit war. Man hat ja gemerkt, man hat nachgerechnet, so wie die Planeten stehen, stehen sie dann lange nicht mehr so. Und wir müssen das jetzt einfach mal schaffen, weil sonst ist einfach diese Gelegenheit weg. Man hat sich in so einem unglaublichen Akt wissenschaftlicher Forschung und Ingenieurs-Baukunst dann doch dazu überreden können, eben diese beiden Missionen zu starten, also Voyager 1, Voyager 2, ja unglaublich erfolgreich sind. Die Dinger funken ja eigentlich beide noch, Voyager 1 auf jeden Fall noch.
Ja, weiß nicht genau.
Einer auf jeden Fall. Und nun sagt man ja, diese Sonde hat das Sonnensystem verlassen. Da gibt es ja dann immer viel Streit darüber, wo denn nun das Sonnensystem aufhört. Ich glaube, man kann festhalten, nein hat es nicht, weil auch da, wo Voyager jetzt noch fliegt, gibt es den Einfluss der Sonne. Und damit ist man sozusagen auch noch Teil des Sonnensystems. Der Einfluss der Sonne verfällt in dem Sinne ja sowieso nie, weil Gravitation nicht irgendwann aufhört. Trotz alledem sind wir halt weit hinter dem letzten bekannten Planeten angekommen in so den ersten Bereichen, wo man ja schon so Worte aufgebracht hat für das Ende. Wie muss man sich das Ende unseres Sonnensystems vorstellen? Also wo fängt sozusagen der Rest des Universums an? Und was ändert sich denn dann auch nennenswert?
Ja, also die Sonne ist ja nur einer von vielen, vielen Sternen in unserer Milchstraße. Und wie wahrscheinlich fast alle Sterne hat sie ein Planetensystem um sich. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie definiert, dass wir da unsere acht Planeten haben. Und die Wolgesonne ist jetzt eben hinter dem Letzten weggeflogen.
Falls es nicht doch diesen ominösen neunten Planeten gibt, der jetzt gerade vorher gesagt wurde.
Also da wird es wahrscheinlich bestimmt noch einige geben. Im Grunde wird es dann noch eine ganze Menge Zeug geben, was man irgendwie gar nicht weiß. Und danach dauert es auch eine ganze Weile, bis man zu ortschen Wolken kommt. Das ist die ganze Wolke, die die ganze Sonne wie so eine Hülle umgibt. Die besteht aus ganz vielen, man weiß es nicht genau, aber wahrscheinlich Eis- und Gesteinsbrocken. Und das ist ja der Ort, wo man denkt, dass die Kometen, die langperiodischen Kometen herkommen. Und das dauert eine ganze Weile, bis die da ankommt, die Sonne. Und danach ist man wirklich im vollkommen interstellaren Raum angekommen. Und dann dauert es eine Weile und dann kommt man zum nächsten Stern. Der nächste Stern ist ja jetzt in den letzten Wochen in den Medien gewesen, weil man dort auch einen Planet in der habitablen Zone entdeckt hat.
Also Proxima Centauri, der auch deswegen so heißt, weil er so nah ist. Also in den üblichen Relativitäten, die man im Universum heranführen muss. Also es ist immer noch sehr weit weg. Ich weiß nicht, wiegen wir?
4,8 oder 4,9 was liegt da. Das ist sehr entfernt und ja, das ist spannend. Auch der Stern hat keine große Überraschung an Planeten. Und da wird sich jetzt auch bestimmt viel Forschung darauf konzentrieren, auf den Planeten. Es gibt ja auch dieses Projekt, das ich ganz spannend finde, dieses heißt das Breakthrough Starshot oder sowas. Das ist doch dieses Projekt, in dem man so Nano-Satelliten mit einem Laser beschleunigen möchte, um dort auf 10% Lichtgeschwindigkeit zu bringen und dort an, um Exoplaneten zu erforschen, also quasi in situ dahin zu schießen. Und das ist ein Projekt, was, glaube ich, die Zukunft ist, dass man eben, wenn man über Voyager hinauskommt, Voyager war der erste Schritt, weit zu fliegen, Missionen zu haben, die eben das unbekannte Weltall, das Unbekannte vorzustoßen, jenseits der bekannten Planeten. Ich glaube, der nächste Schritt ist wahrscheinlich sowas, dass man Satelliten nimmt.
Zehn Prozent der Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Das heißt, man bräuchte 50 Jahre zu Proxima Centauri.
Genau.
Aber man bräuchte auch nochmal 50 Jahre.
Die kommen nicht zurück.
Ne, fünf Jahre, um die Signal zurückzusenden.
Genau. Was nicht verrückt ist.
Ne, das geht schon.
Also man braucht auch, ja, das geht schon. Also das ist schon okay. Und wie das funktionieren soll, ist, dass man eben mit extrem starken Lasern, die wahrscheinlich irgendwo im Orbit oder im Mond sein müssen, eben über den Strahlungsdruck diese Satelliten beschleunigt. Diese Satelliten sind wirklich extrem klein. Also das sind, ich weiß nicht, weniger als einen Gramm, glaube ich, oder so. Was sollen die groß sein?
Weniger als einen Gramm.
Ja.
Können die auch noch Informationen zurückschicken dann?
Jaja, das ist alles das, was man da denkt. Also ich bin ja kein Experte auf dem Gebiet, aber ich glaube, dass das die Zukunft ist. Dass das so das nächste Voyager ist, was man da macht, um eben diese Exoplaneten zu erforschen. Und das ist dann eben der nächste Stern, ob der jetzt in der Habe wirklich ihr Leben da drauf ist oder nicht. Das wird sich dann herausstellen, wahrscheinlich schon relativ bald. Aber irgendwann wird man Leben finden. Hoffentlich bin ich dann noch am Leben.
Okay, jetzt Orto Volke. Auch da ist Voyager noch nicht, aber Voyager hat schon Bereiche durchkreuzt, die klangvolle Namen haben, wie die Heliopause fällt mir jetzt gerade ein. Aber das erzähl ich jetzt nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge. Was macht man denn da sozusagen für Phasen aus? Was gibt so die aktuelle astronomische Definition her, wie man diese Bereiche bezeichnet?
Ja, also ich bin ja jetzt nicht so der Experte für die genaue Definition, wann jetzt das Sonnensystem da aufhört. Und da will ich mich gar nicht groß zu sagen. Aber was das Interessante daran ist, an der jetzigen Phase von Voyager, jetzt aus meiner Sicht ist zum einen, dass sie eben die Heliopause durchflogen ist. Dass man eben misst, etwas lernt über die Plasmaphysik. Da lernt man weniger eigentlich etwas über Astronomie. Hat natürlich alles was damit zu tun, aber eher über die Plasmaphysik. Wie denn unter solchen extremen Bedingungen, wie dort Stoßwellen funktionieren, wie den Magnetfelder im All funktionieren. Das ist eigentlich interessant. Das andere, was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass man eben jetzt auch sieht, dass andere Teilchen gemessen werden. Nicht mehr Teilchen, die nur im Grunde aus dem Sonnensystem kommen, sondern dass man auch Teilchen misst, die aus dem interstellaren Raum kommen. Und das ist natürlich interessant. Die Sonne hat sich eben aus dem interstellaren Medium geformt. Was ist denn die, und im Grunde ist unsere In-situ-Messungen bislang auf das Sonnensystem beschränkt gewesen, aber wenn man jetzt zum allerersten Mal wirklich Teilchen misst, die von außerhalb kommen, das ist natürlich spannend.
Ich muss mich korrigieren. Termination Shock, das ist sozusagen da, wo Voyager 1 durch ist. Bei der Heliopause sind noch ein paar Meter. Aber das ist sozusagen der Anfang des Endes des Einflusses der Sonne. Und bei der Heliopause ist dann halt so richtig vorbei. Und was dann kommt, weißer Geier. Wenn man jetzt auf den Himmel schaut, ich hatte das jetzt auch gerade jüngst hier im neu eröffneten Groß-Size-Planetarium mit dem ganz neuen Sternenprojektor ganz toll, da sieht man halt viele Sterne. Die sind halt im Wesentlichen in der Milchstraße. Aber dann, wenn man wirklich sehr genau schaut, sieht man ja auch eine weitere Galaxie. Die ist jetzt mit dem bloßen Auge auf der Erde so nicht zu entdecken. Ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, was braucht man für Teleskope, bis man zu Andromeda schauen kann.
Das kann man mit einem ganz einfachen Feldstecher machen. Wirklich? Also man kann, wenn man...
Das ist das Dunkelste meiner Runde.
Ja, genau. Das Schwierigste ist wirklich, einen Ort zu finden, der dunkel genug ist. Also wenn man auf die Südhalbkugel fliegt, zum Beispiel als ich in Chile mal war, vor kurzer Zeit, wenn man da einen Ort hat, wo es wirklich sehr dunkel ist, da sieht man die Magellanischen Wolken, zum Beispiel mit bloßem Auge. Das sind auch Satellitengalaxien der Milchstraße. Kleine, die näher sind. Die große und die kleine Magellanische Wolke. Und die sieht man mit dem bloßen Auge. Und ja, das kann ich jedem empfehlen, wenn man immer die Chance hat, auf der Südhalbkugel zu sein.
Die sieht man nur dort.
Die sieht man nur dort. Und das ist eigentlich ein bisschen interessant, weil diese Dinger riesengroß sind. Man denkt immer, Galaxien, wenn man die beobachtet, sind Mini-Objekte, sind riesen Dinger. Die sind relativ, die Oberflächenhelligkeit ist gering. Man muss deswegen wirklich an einem sehr dunklen Ort sein. Die Augen müssen sich gut an die Dunkelheit gewöhnen. Aber dann sieht man diese großen Satelliten, Galaxien, die Nachbarn der Milchstraße, die Milchstraße im Grunde umkreisen oder die gravitativ gebunden sind an die Milchstraße. Und Andromeda kann man mit einem Feldstecher beobachten.
Oh, aber auch nicht hier?
Die kann man hier beobachten.
Wann hat sich denn dieses Bild von Galaxien und dieses Verständnis, dass das, was wir sehen, eigentlich nur eins von vielen ist, überhaupt gebildet? Also wann hat man denn verstanden, dass diese Sterne da draußen eigentlich so Nachbarschaft sind und nur sehr wenig von dem, was man sieht, ganz woanders ist?
Ja, also das ist nicht lange her. Es gab diese große Debatte, wo debattiert wurde, ob diese Nebel, die man schon vor langer Zeit im Grunde gesehen hatte, ob das Teile sind unserer Milchstraße, die wir heute unsere Milchstraße nehmen, oder ob das separate Sternenwelten sind, separate Galaxien sind.
Hat man sich schon gefragt.
Das hat man sich dann gefragt und da gab es diese große Debatte.
Aber erst jüngst gefragt.
Diese Debatte war, jetzt komme ich wieder darauf hin, dass ich mir nichts merken kann, wann die genau war. Das müsstest du mal im Internet nachgucken. Wann die genau war. Das kommt auch in meiner Vorlesung vor. Ich muss nämlich für jede Vorlesung nachlesen, wann das war.
Oder gab es mehrere. Aber die große Debatte der Astronomie 1920.
Hubble Zeiten. Und da die große Debatte, da hatte genau das zum Thema. Und seit kurz danach hatte man eben herausgefunden, dass die anderen Nebel, wie man sie damals genannt hatte, wirklich separate Sternenwelten sind, separate Galaxien sind. Und seitdem hat sich das Feld eben so enorm entwickelt, dass wir heute hunderttausende von Galaxien kennen.
Das heißt, noch nicht mal vor 100 Jahren gab es den Begriff Galaxie gar nicht?
Genau. Das finde ich immer das besonders frappierende.
Weil das ja auch eigentlich einer der populärsten und sexy Begriffe dieser ganzen Raumfahrtwelt ist.
Man kann sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen, dass man irgendwie nicht weiß, dass es hier in der Milchstraße wohnen, dass es andere Milchstraßen gibt und ganz viele davon. Heutzutage wissen und haben wir vermessen hunderttausende von Galaxien. Und das sind bei Wahl nicht alle von denen, die wir vermessen können.
Also die Astronomen Sheppley und Curtis, was dazu führt, dass hier in der Wikipedia diese Debatte als die Sheppley-Curtis-Debatte bezeichnet wird, die haben sich da sozusagen darüber gestritten, wie es denn nun sei mit der Milchstraße und wie groß denn das alles nun zu fassen sei. Aber in der Folge hat sich dann sozusagen diese sich durchgesetzt, weil sie ja wohl offensichtlich auch stimmt. Was weiß man denn jetzt sozusagen über diese, also was definiert eine Galaxie? Und vielleicht kann man das einfach mal an der Milchstraße festmachen, die ja so im Prinzip so unser Bezirk ist im Weltall. Was macht eine Galaxie und was macht konkret unsere Galaxie aus?
Ja, also eine Galaxie ist eine Ansammlung von vielen Sternen, und das heißt jetzt von Millionen oder mehr Sternen, die alle in einem Gravitationswelt gebunden sind. Die sich irgendwie in einem gemeinsamen Gravitationsfeld bewegen. Galaxien bestehen neben Sternen aus dunkler Materie und aus Gas und Staub. Und wahrscheinlich hat auch jede Galaxie mindestens ein supermassives Schwarzloch im Zentrum. Und Galaxien gibt es in aller möglichen Formen. Auf Hubble geht so eine Klassifikation zurück. Die Galaxien in Spiralgalaxien und in elliptische Galaxien unterteilt sind die beiden Hauptklassen von Galaxien. Es gibt mehr Spiralgalaxien als elliptische Galaxien. Dann gibt es noch irreguläre Galaxien, Zwerggalaxien. Und wenn man da genau einsteigt, diese ganzen Klassifikationen, gibt es dann einen ganzen Zoo von Galaxien. Und die Milchstraße ist eine Spiralgalaxie. Also das ist eine Scheibe. Die meisten Sterne sind eine Scheibe, die um ein Gemeindamm ins Zentrum rotiert. Alle 200 Millionen Jahre geht es einmal herum.
Wie das auch innerhalb unseres Sonnensystems ist.
Genau, alles bewegt sich, alles rotiert.
Aber ist denn die Scheibe unseres Sonnensystems auch identisch mit der Scheibe der Milchstraße? Die können alle irgendwie stehen.
Genau, das ist unabhängig voneinander. Wenn man die Milchstraße sieht am Himmel, schauen wir die Scheibe an. Deswegen ist es die Milchstraße.
Deswegen ist es ein Band.
Genau, und das ist eben das Band der Milchstraße. Das ist eben ein Spreigalaxie. Die Sterne, die rotieren da. Die bewegen sich um das gemeinsame Zentrum. Die Sonne ist eher in einem Außenbezirk der Milchstraße. 8 Kilopaseck in den Einheiten, die die Astronomen gerne benutzen.
8 Kilopaseck?
Das sind 24.000 Lichtjahre vom Zentrum der Galaxie.
Was ist denn ein Paseck?
Ein Paseck ist drei Lichtjahre.
Ein Paseck ist drei Lichtjahre?
Ungefähr drei Lichtjahre.
Warum schafft man denn dafür noch eine eigene Einheit, wenn es nur drei?
Weil Lichtjahre eigentlich eine blöde Einheit ist. Weil Lichtjahre nichts ist, was direkt aus einer Messung verfolgt. Paseck ist eine gute Einheit, weil es steht, ist die Abkürzung für Parallax Second. Das heißt, das ist die Entfernung, die eine Parallaxe von einer Bogensekunde erzeugt. Und Parallaxe ist der, so wie Gaia, wo du letztens ja einen Podcast so hattest, wie Gaia die Abstände misst von Sternen in der Milchstraße durch Parallax. Und Parallaxe ist eben der scheinbare Positionswechsel eines Sterns über den Verlauf eines Jahres. Weil wir dann den Stern unter einem anderen Winkel im Sommer sehen als im Winter. Weil dann die Erde auf der anderen Seite der Sonne ist.
Also aufgrund von der Erddrehung.
Genau, aufgrund von der Erddrehung. Also etwas, was man direkt misst, was direkt mit einer Messung, einer Beobachtungsgröße hergeleitet wird.
Okay, also der normale Jitter sozusagen der Beobachtung, das ist die Parallaxe. Und eine Parallaxensekunde ist dann sozusagen eine Bogensekunde, eine Unterteilung davon.
Und dann weiß man, wenn jetzt etwas, eine Parallaxe von einer Bogensekunde ist, dann weiß man, dass es ein paar Sekunden entfernt. Und deswegen ist das eine. Und so haben sich eben die ganzen Einheiten in der exagalaktischen Astrophysik sind alle basierend auf einem paar Sekunden. Während eher so in der Planetenforschung man meistens mit astronomischen Einheiten arbeitet, Astronomische Units, also die mittlere Entfernung zwischen Erde und Sonne.
Also acht Lichtminuten.
Acht Lichtminuten. Genau. Und Lichtjahre ist etwas, was eher aus Science-Fiction kommt oder aus dem, das irgendwie in der populären Wahrnehmung immer da ist, aber in der Astronomie rechnet keiner mehr Lichtjahre.
Nachvollziehbar. Man muss ja immer die Einheit nehmen, die auch am praktischsten ist und irgendwie passt. Sonst muss man ja die ganze Zeit umrechnen und hat kein Verständnis dafür. Aber Lichtjahre muss man ja sagen, also nicht jeder versteht das so. Wird ja auch gerne mal so als Zeitanwälte wahrgenommen. Das dauert ja Lichtjahre, was ich jetzt lustig finde. Aber immerhin, auch das ist eine Menge Holz. Gut, jetzt hast du gesagt, die Galaxie ist... Worauf hast du dich gerade bezogen? Auf den Durchmesser der...
Unser Abstand vom Zentrum, im Grunde vom Schwarzen Loch in der Mitte der Milchstraße.
Für Trig?
8 Kiloparseck, also ungefähr 24.000. 24.000 Lichtjahre.
Okay, das heißt das Licht, was von dort nicht kommt, aber wenn man dort hinschaut, alles was man noch wahrnimmt, das ist schon mal 24.000 Jahre unterwegs gewesen, um bis zu uns zu kommen. Wir sind innerhalb der Milchstraße wie weit draußen? Also sind wir schon so unter Fernerliefen oder sind wir eher so mittendrin?
Also wir sind eben diese 24.000 Lichtjahre draußen vom Zentrum.
Ja gut, aber da kommen ja noch ein paar andere Sterne hinter uns.
Ja, wir sind eher schon so draußen. Viel kommt dann nachher nicht mehr. Das nimmt dann relativ bald ab. So eine genaue Grenze gibt es dann nicht. Es wird halt eben immer weniger. Das nimmt eben ab. Und wir sind eher schon so in einem Außenbezirk.
Also der Anhalter hat recht gehabt, da hieß es ja in einem ziemlich uninteressanten Bereich.
Genau, ein relativ uninteressanter Stern in einem uninteressanten, unbedeutenden Block des Universums. Und da ist eben die Sonne da. Und im Zentrum der Milchstraße gibt es eben ein schwarzes Loch, ein supermassives schwarzes Loch, das man relativ genau vermessen kann. Das ist ungefähr eine Million Sonnenmassen an Masse. Und das ist eher klein für solche supermassiven schwarzen Löcher, dafür ist die Milchstraße eigentlich eher eine relativ schwere Spiralgalaxie. Und die gehört teilweise zu einer Gruppe von Galaxien, die zu einer lokalen Gruppe gehören. Die Andromeda-Galaxie ist auch ein Teil der lokalen Gruppe. Die Milchstraße ist die größte, die dominante Galaxie dieser lokalen Gruppe. Und da gehören halt verschiedene Galaxien dazu. Kleinere Zwerggalaxien hauptsächlich. Und die entdeckt man auch eher, die meisten davon kannte man auch noch nicht vor all zu langer Zeit. Das sind meist lichtschwache Galaxien und diese Satelliten werden eben sukzessive entdeckt. Und es gibt viel Interesse eigentlich im Moment besonders für diese ganz kleinen Galaxien, weil das eben sehr Probleme gibt mit unserem kosmologischen Modell. So vielleicht später.
Okay, um es dann mal zusammenzufassen, um es auch mal klar gesagt zu haben. Also unsere Sonne ist eine von na, was ist die aktuelle Schätzung? Wie viel Sonnen gibt es so in der Milchstraße? Ich hab mal was von 100 Milliarden bis 200 Milliarden gehört. Man hat keine Ahnung. Also die Gaia-Mission, die du schon angesprochen hattest, wo es hier auch schon mal einen Podcast zu gab, als die ganze Mission noch auf dem Weg war. Mittlerweile hat sie ja nicht nur funktioniert, sondern vor ein paar Tagen eben auch schon die ersten Daten abgeworfen, ist ja dabei, diese Milchstraße komplett neu zu vermessen. Also auch natürlich alles andere, was noch zu sehen ist. Aber vor allem geht es darum, ein neues Verständnis der Milchstraße zu finden und mal wirklich die Sterne genau zu zählen. Also ich glaube, die Präzision, mit der das jetzt getan wird, ist um ein Vielfaches höher als die Sternenkarten, die wir bisher zur Verfügung haben. Und auch die pure Zahl von Sternen, die überhaupt gesehen wird, übersteigt das natürlich auch nochmal um mehrere Maßeinheiten.
Die wollen glaube ich eine Milliarde Sterne vermessen.
Eine Milliarde Sterne, genau. Also man weiß, man sieht ohnehin nicht alle, aber man kann schon irgendwie auf der Basis interpolieren, was vielleicht so in etwa die größten Ordnung ist. Also du wirst sie jetzt auf keine Zahl festlegen lassen. Es sind auf jeden Fall sau viele. Und davon sind wir halt irgendwie ein kleiner Fleck, der von den allermeisten überhaupt nicht gesehen wird. Die rotieren alle um dieses schwarze Loch herum, was vielleicht nicht besonders schwer ist, aber was hast du gesagt, eine Million Sonnen? Eine Million Sonnen. Also sozusagen eine Million Mal so viel Masse, wie unsere Sonne aufbietet, befindet sich da in der Mitte und saugt quasi an allem anderen. Alles andere hängt mehr oder weniger nur an diesem schwarzen Loch. Kann man sich das nicht vorstellen.
Genau, das ist etwas, was mich viele Leute fragen und was oft falsch verstanden wird. Die Leute denken, dass das schwarze Loch wie so ein kosmischer Staubsauger ist und das ist immer total gefährlich. Wie in den Science fiction Filmen frisst das ja auch immer alles auf. Dieses schwarze Loch ist eigentlich relativ unbedeutend. Zunächst einmal. Also die Gravitation von diesem schwarzen Loch ist eher unbedeutend. Wenn man das schwarze Loch jetzt da wegnehmen würde, da würde es jetzt genauso rumfliegen. Und man kann auch recht nah an dem schwarzen Loch recht nah mit Einschränkungen vorbeifliegen und nichts passiert, weil die Sonne ist auch schwer und wir stürzen trotzdem nie in die Sonne herein. Und das schwarze Loch ist auch nur eine Masse. In der Nähe rum schwören viele Sterne rum. Es ist auch ein interessantes Forschungsgebiet, was da in der Nähe des schwarzen Loch passiert. Aber das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Denn das große Problem ist, herauszufinden, warum diese schwarzen Löcher in den Zentren von Galaxien überhaupt so schwer sind. Denn es ist besonders schwer, schwarze Löcher zu füttern. Im Gegenteil zu dem, was man immer denkt. Man denkt immer, schwarze Löcher sind diese großen Materiefresser. Aber es ist sehr schwer, diese schwarzen Löcher zu füttern. Denn in ein schwarzes Loch zu stürzen, ist extrem schwer. Genauso wie es schwer ist, genau in die Sonne zu stürzen. Denn wir kreisen und die Sonne auf irgendeine Bahn, Kreisbahn oder elliptische Bahn. Und da gibt es eine Erhaltungsgröße in der Physik, das ist der Drehmoment. Und der muss halt erhalten bleiben. Deswegen ist es sehr schwer, überhaupt irgendwo rein zu stürzen. Um irgendwo rein zu stürzen, muss man bremsen. Also Drehmoment verlieren, man muss abbremsen, Reibung erzeugen. Und im interstellaren Raum gibt es wenig Reibung. Das heißt, irgendwelche Sterne oder die Erde erfährt auch keine Reibung. Weil sie keine Reibung erfährt, könnte die Sonne so groß sein, wie sie wollte.
Aber reicht es nicht einfach direkt drauf zuzufliegen?
Ja, aber die Chancen, dass irgendwie die Bahn zufälligerweise so ist, dass es direkt da drauf geht, die sind extrem klein. Also das heißt, sobald du irgendwie, wenn du da drauf gehst, einen gewissen Abstand zu dem Schwarzen Loch hast, hast du automatisch einen Drehimpuls. Und diesen Drehimpuls, den wirst du nicht los, es sei denn, du hast irgendwie die Bremskräfte. Und kein Mensch weiß, woher diese Bremskräfte kommen sollten, um eben in der Schwarze Loch zu kommen. Wenn man dann irgendwann sehr nah ran kommt, in ein Radius, den man Schwadschild-Radius, das ist da, wo der Ereignishorizont ist. Und wenn man ein paar von diesen Schwadschild-Radien entfernt kommt, dann gibt es Effekte der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie. Und die können das dann beschleunigen. Aber um so in diese Nähe zu kommen, das ist extrem schwer.
Ich kann das ganz gut nachvollziehen. Ich hatte ja mal dieses Erlebnis in einem Parabelflug und in dem Moment, wo man einfach Schwerelosigkeit erfährt, also Mikro-Gravitation heißt das ja korrekt gesprochen, aber auf einmal ist man halt nicht mehr schwer. Und dann merkt man halt erst mal so, oh weia, jetzt treibe ich in eine Richtung und ich kann rumhampeln, wie ich will. Ich habe keine Chance, keine Möglichkeit umzukehren. Das ist so ein Gefühl, was wir einfach auf der Erde kaum kennen. Also es sei ein Fallschirmspringer oder so, aber da hat man auch noch eine ganze Menge Luft und kann da irgendwie rumfliegen. Das hilft einem an der Stelle überhaupt nicht mehr. Schon gar nicht natürlich, wenn es gar keine Atmosphäre gibt. Und ja, da kann ich mir das jetzt irgendwie ganz gut vorstellen, wie das so ist, wenn man so, nein, ich will rein in das Schwarze Loch. Aber nein, leider eine Bogensekunde. Wobei. Sorry. Okay, also dieses Schwarze Loch spielt irgendeine Rolle. Es gibt immer welche, offenbar in Galaxien. Weiß man, ist das irgendwie Zwangsloch? Also es scheint ja irgendwie eine zwangsläufige Entwicklung zu sein, dass sich dort so etwas bildet. Aber warum tut es das? Ist das eher so ein Abfallprodukt? Weil es halt die Mitte ist und da mehr oder weniger alle irgendwo hingezogen werden und ein paar fallen da halt rein, oder?
Ja, also das ist eine ganz große, ganz spannende Frage in der Astronomie. Was denn diese Rolle und was dieser Ursprung dieser Schwarzen Löcher ist. Und das weiß man nicht. Was klar ist, dass eben die meisten Galaxien solche Schwarzen Löcher haben und diese Schwarzen Löcher also so massiv sind. Und dass die schon Galaxien, die sehr weit weg sind, also sehr alt sind, auch schon so Schwarze Löcher haben, die sehr schwer sind. Also die müssen sich schon relativ früh in der Entwicklung des Universums gebildet haben. Aber weil es eben so schwer ist, diese Schwarzen Löcher zu bilden, ist es eben die Frage, wie kommen die, wie werden die so schnell so schwer? Da gibt es verschiedene Theorien dazu, aber das ist noch nicht entschieden. Man weiß es also nicht. Und die Schwarzen Löcher sind jetzt von ihrer Schwerkraft für die Galaxien, für das Leben und die Bahnen der ganzen Sterne in den Galaxien egal. Aber diese, offensichtlich sind diese, nicht ganz so offensichtlich, aber diese Schwarzen Löcher sind für das ganze Leben der Galaxien wahrscheinlich entscheidend. Und das ist ein bisschen ein Rätsel, wie diese Schwarzen Löcher, die zwar schwer sind, aber deren Einflusssphäre eigentlich relativ gering ist, warum diese Schwarzen Löcher das Leben der gesamten Galaxie bestimmen. Und das tun sie. Oder andersrum. Das nennt man, dieses Ganze nennt man Co-Evolution von Schwarzen Löchern und Galaxien, dass die irgendwie miteinander zu tun haben. Denn die Schwarzen Löcher, die korrelieren mit den Eigenschaften, mit bestimmten Eigenschaften von diesen Galaxien. Also die Galaxien haben, je nachdem, wie gewiss Teile der Galaxie beschaffen sind, haben eben dann die Schwarze Löcher genau dieselben Eigenschaften. Und das heißt, was man daraus schließt, ist, dass die Schwarzen Löcher die Bildung der Galaxie steuern. Und das ist, weiß man nicht wie, weil ja eigentlich die Einfossphäre doch so gering ist von diesen Schwarzen Löchern. Und wie das wahrscheinlich passiert, ist, dass diese Schwarzen Löcher zum Beispiel bestimmen die Schwarzen Löcher die Sternbildungsrate von den Galaxien. Wie viele Sterne eine Galaxie produziert. Wie viele Sonnenmassen an neuen Sternen pro Jahr in einer Galaxie gebildet werden. Das ist die Sternbildungsrate. Die Sternbildungsrate, normalerweise müssten die Galaxien eigentlich viel größer sein, als sie eigentlich sind. Die Galaxien sind eigentlich klein. Dabei ist so viel Gas in die Galaxien da, das relativ, das nur darauf wartet, Sterne zu werden, Sterne zu bilden. Aber das wird unterdrückt. Und der große Unterdrücker von all dem sind die Schwarzen Löcher. Wie die das machen, ist, dass während Gas diese Schwarze Löcher umkreist, bildet dieses Gas so Materieausflüsse, so Jets nennt man das, die dann zu meist zwei Seiten, gegenüberliegende Seiten in den Schwarzen Löchern dort eben Winde rauspusten, ganz kollimierte, wie so Strahlen an Winden rauspusten. Und diese Winde, die verhindern, dass die Sterne bilden. Die pusten immer wieder Gas raus.
Die bringen uns quasi Unruhe.
Die bilden Unruhe in das System. Und das ist eben im Moment zumindestens die beste Theorie dafür, warum diese schwarzen Löcher eben diese Galaxien so bestimmen.
Aber wie weit können denn diese Winde dieser schwarzen Löcher abstrahlen? Ich meine, wenn wir jetzt schon 24.000 Lichtjahre entfernt sind, ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie jetzt eine nennenswerte Größe ist in galaktischen Dimensionen. Also kann es sein, dass diese Winde dieses schwarzen Loches auch da, wo wir sind, noch einen nennenswerten Einfluss haben?
Genau, das ist eine gute Frage. Und da kommen jetzt wieder die Radioteleskope rein, weil diese Winde sieht man eben nur mit Radioteleskopen. Und die sieht man nicht im optischen Bereich. Dafür sind sie nur lichtschwaches. Das Gas, das da eben rausfliegt ab, das Gas hat eben Elektronen drin, die extrem schnell sind und die kreisen um Magnetfelder und pulzieren in Radialwellen. Deswegen kann man die sehen. Was man da sieht, ist, dass diese schwarzen Löcher diese Materiestrahlen pulzieren, die weit über die Galaxie hinausgehen. Es gibt sogar ganz extreme Bereiche, extreme Beispiele, wo diese Ausflüsse Millionen von Lichtjahren weit rausgehen. Also Megaparsec.
Und die auch davon abhängig sind, wie massiv dieses schwarze Loch ist?
Ja, die wahrscheinlich davon abhängig sind, wie massiv das schwarze Loch ist. Aber wahrscheinlich noch mehr davon abhängen, wie viel Gas gerade auf das schwarze Loch einfällt und gegen was, wie viel Gas im Weg ist von diesen Materiestrahlen, die das abbrennen könnte oder das rausschieben muss. Im leeren Raum können die viel weiter reisen als wenn sie gegen dichte Materie blockiert werden.
Ich habe jetzt schon wieder dieses Problem, dass ich meine, genug von schwarzen Löchern verstanden zu haben, ohne das groß zu hinterfragen. Das will ich gleich mal verhindern. Nur damit sich jemand dem der Begriff schwarzes Loch auch noch nicht so richtig erschlossen hat, nochmal, dass das auch klar werden kann. Ein schwarzes Loch ist sozusagen so eine, ich formuliere es mal ganz einfach, so eine überkollabierte Sonne, die so dermaßen schwer geworden ist, dass sie so viel Gravitation entwickelt, dass sie alles an sich reißt, aber eben auch das Licht selbst diesen Ort nicht mehr verlassen kann. Ist das ein richtiges Bild, was ich hier liefere? Und lange Zeit hat man, glaube ich, doch auch gedacht, naja, wenn da nichts raus kann, also wenn schon das Licht da nicht raus kann, dann kann da auch nichts raus. Trotzdem weiß man mittlerweile auch so ein schwarzes Loch, liefert diese Materie in irgendeiner Form wieder zurück eben über diese Jets.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen eins von diesen Beispielen, wo Astronomen oft immer so salopp daherreden und dadurch das so ein bisschen von falscher Eindruck entsteht, was einmal im Ereignishorizont des schwarzen Lochs wirklich drin ist und wirklich verschluckt wird, so wie das Licht da auch nicht mehr rauskommt. Das kommt tatsächlich nicht mehr raus. Ein Prozess, der dann auf Hawking zurückgeht, wo das vielleicht anders ist, aber worüber ich jetzt spreche, worüber die Astronomen sprechen, über die ganzen großen Winde, diese Materieausflüsse aus schwarzen Löchern, das entsteht alles in der Aggressionsscheibe, also in einer großen Scheibe von Gas, die um das schwarze Loch herumschwappt und in der dann eben große Reibungskräfte entstehen und die dann dazu führen, dass das Gas abgebremst wird, seinen Drehimpuls verliert und dann langsam in das schwarze Loch hineinfällt. Wenn das einmal wirklich im Ereignisserozonen drin ist, dann kommt es noch nicht mehr raus. Aber das ganz interessante, astronomische, passiert viele Schwarzschildradien außerhalb dieses Bereichs, dort wo das Gas sich extremst stark aufheizt und dort um der schwarze Loch herum kreist, auch wieder in einer Scheibe.
Okay, das ist sozusagen der Vorort des schwarzen Lochs, wo es einfach wild abgeht und dort entstehen dann diese krassen Jets. Das heißt, es ist im Prinzip so ein Teil wird verschluckt, aber ein Teil wird quasi wieder mit einer enormen Energie, die auch die Massivität dieses schwarzen Loches widerspiegelt, wieder zurückgeschleudert. Das heißt, das schwarze Loch innerhalb der Galaxis ist quasi so ein Störfaktor, der saugt Gas ein und hält quasi die Galaxie in Wallung. Wo kann man sich das vorstellen?
Wie so ein Thermostat, muss man sich vorstellen. So ein bisschen so ein großer Regulierer.
Sonst würde sich einfach aus allem irgendwie eine Sonne bilden, das wäre auch langweilig, deswegen hält er das sozusagen die ganze Zeit in Wallung.
Das ist eine relativ neue Erkenntnis.
Heißt? Was ist relativ neu?
Dass diese schwarzen Löcher überhaupt korrelieren mit den Eigenschaften der Galaxien und die deswegen aufeinander einen Einfluss haben, der den ganzen Leben parallel verfolgen. Das weiß man seit ungefähr 1994, 1994, 1995. Und tatsächlich seitdem hält sich dieses ganze Problem. Und mittlerweile versteht man das relativ gut, aber ganz genau weiß man es immer noch nicht. Besonders weiß man noch nicht, wo die schwarzen Löcher wirklich herkommen. Was die ursprünglich bildet. Ob die im frühen Universum irgendwie schon irgendwelche Saatkörner, Saatlöcher gibt, die dann irgendwie schon schwer waren. Oder ob die am Anfang es irgendeine Phase gibt im Universum, wo die wie verrückt wachsen.
Gehen wir mal weg von der Mehstraße. Du hast ja schon angesprochen, um uns herum kreisen noch andere Galaxien. Die größte ist die Andromeda-Galaxie, die man auch mit dem Feldstecher sehen kann, wenn es dunkel genug ist, was es bei uns normalerweise nicht ist. Die dominieren einen Bereich, den man lokale Gruppe nennt, d.h. außer diesen beiden relativ schweren Galaxien gibt es noch eine ganze Menge Kleinstgalaxien, die so rumfliegen und irgendwie auch noch so ein bisschen Teil davon sind. Kleinstgalaxie ist natürlich auch ein interessantes Wort. Wenn man so etwas unglaublich unfassbar Großes nimmt und davon eine Miniaturversion hat, dann ist das ja immer noch ziemlich groß. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Was sind so diese Größenordnungen dieser kleineren Galaxien, die noch zur lokalen Gruppe dazugehören? Wenn wir so, wenn man mal sagt, wir haben 100 Milliarden Sterne, auch wenn wir diese Zahl nicht bestätigen können, ist das dann so eine Milliarde, ist das so ein Hundertstel groß oder sind die noch kleiner?
Ja, also die können noch kleiner werden, also nur ein paar Millionen Sterne, so ganz kleine Zwerggalaxien haben, die nur so 1000 Lichtjahre im Durchmesser sind. Solche Galaxien, gibt es auch Galaxien, die ganz interessant sind, weil sie sehr wenig Sterne haben und fast hauptsächlich noch mehr dominiert werden von dunkler Materie als andere Galaxien. Davon gibt es ganz viele von diesen lichtschwachen Systemen.
Haben die doch auch alle ein schwarzes Loch?
Die haben wahrscheinlich auch ein schwarzes Loch und deswegen sind die wahrscheinlich auch noch lichtschwächer, als sie eigentlich trotz ihrer Masse sein müssen, weil die eben dann auch nicht so viel Schwerkraft haben. Deswegen kann eben, wenn da irgendwas drin passiert in diesen Galaxien, wie zum Beispiel Supernovae-Explosionen am Lebensende der Sterne darin oder schwarze Löcher, dass die das ganze Gas rauspusten und dann war es das mit der Galaxie. Im Sinne von da wird jetzt auch nichts mehr ein Stern gebildet. Deswegen wird die da immer lichtschwächer. Deswegen sind das interessante Objekte eigentlich. Ob die alle ein schwarzes Loch haben, das weiß man nicht. Diese ganz kleinen Galaxien. Und oft sind die sehr lichtschwach und die können eben sehr schnell, die sind eben anfällig für diese ganzen Winde und diese ganzen schweren Sachen. Das ist bei der Milchstraße nicht so leicht. Aber auch unser schwarzes Loch ist aktiv. Man hat jetzt vor ein paar Jahren rausgefunden mit Gammastrahlenteleskopen, dass es sowas gibt. Das heißt, die Fermiblasen, das sind irgendwie Blasen, die aus der Scheibe der Galaxie rausgehen. Ganz große, blasenartigen Gebilde von kosmischer Strahlung, von ganz, sind wie so riesen Luftballons, die gefüllt sind mit energetischen Teilchen, die oberhalb und unterhalb der Scheibe ebenso senkrechter zu stehen und die von dem schwarzen Loch pulziert werden. Also auch irgendwie überbleibste wahrscheinlich von solchen Aktivitäten des schwarzen Loches. Also schwarze Löcher sind aktive Dinger und die sieht man eben hauptsächlich in anderen Wellenlängen, nicht im optischen Bereich. Deswegen ist eigentlich diese Multiwellenlänge, Astronomie, in anderen Wellenlängen so fundamental wichtig, um so Sachen wie Galaxien zu verstehen. Man muss sehen, das letzte Jahrhundert war im Grunde so ein Jahrhundert, in dem die große Erfolgsstory in der Astronomie war, dass man Sterne versteht. Das ist auch nicht so einfach, aber die Menschen haben es geschafft, Sterne sehr gut zu verstehen. Wir können Sterne, wenn wir sie beobachten, wir können das Alter sagen, wir wissen genau, wie sie sich entwickeln. Das verstehen wir extrem gut. Wir wissen, woraus sie entstehen, ist nur das schwere Problem. Genau, woraus sie bestehen. Wenn sich einmal ein Stern gebildet hat, wissen wir das Extrems, können wir genau vorhersagen, was mit jedem Stern passiert. Galaxien ist so ein bisschen die Herausforderung dieser Tage, dass man die Entwicklung von Galaxien noch nicht so gut versteht. Dazu kommt eben der, ist es halt schwieriger, als man gedacht hatte, weil es irgendwie schwarze Löcher gibt. Da gibt es viele physikalische Prozesse, die alle scheinen da irgendwie beizutragen, aber es ist nicht klar, wie fern. Bei den Sternen sind es im Grunde drei, vier fundamentale Prozesse, und die führen zu einem Gleichungssystem. Dieses Gleichungssystem hat man gelöst, und das kennt man jetzt, und das ist verstanden, mehr oder weniger. Es gibt bestimmt einige Stellarastronomen, die jetzt auf die Barrikaden gehen, weil ich ihr Forschungsfeld verunglimpfe. Aber im Großen und Ganzen halte ich das für eine Erfolgsstory, dass man Sterne so gut versteht. Bei Galaxien ist es nicht so, die sind relativ schwer, die sind relativ schlecht verstanden. Warum den Galaxien? Was denn ist das? Ich habe jetzt über die ganz kleinen Galaxien gesprochen. Die ganz schweren Galaxien sind große elliptische Galaxien, hauptsächlich in den Zentren von so Galaxienhaufen, große elliptische Gebilde, viel schwerer als die Milchstraße. Auch die sind mysteriös. Warum die denn nicht noch schwerer sind, da bildet sich relativ wenig Sterne mehr. Auch das sind, die haben riesen schwarzen Löcher, zum Beispiel der nächste Galaxienhaufen ist der Virgo-Haufen. Und da gibt es im Zentrum eine ganz große elliptische Galaxie, die heißt M87, wegen Messier-Katalog und das hat ein Schwarzschlauch von mehr als Milliarden Sonnenmassen, M87, also die Zentralgalaxie im Virgo-Haufen. Milliarden Sonnenmassen, riesen schwarzen Löcher. Was für ein Einfluss. Und da gibt es auch diese riesen Jets, die da vorkommen, die wohl studiert sind, weil es relativ nahe ist. Und das ist völlig unverstanden, warum denn, wie diese Galaxien sich zu solchen entwickeln, wo man sie zu solchen entwickelt. Auch scheint die Umgebung zum Beispiel eine Rolle zu spielen. Je nachdem, wo die Galaxien so leben. Leben sie in einem dichten Teil des Universums oder in einem wenig dichten Teil des Universums?
Bevor wir auf diese Verteilung kommen, würde ich noch mal ganz gerne so ein bisschen vom Bezirk zum Ort, zum Bundesland kommen. Also Sonnensystem ist Teil der Milchstraße. Milchstraße ist Teil der lokalen Gruppe, die sich im Wesentlichen aus Andromeda und Milchstraße und dem ganzen kleinen Kleckerkram mit nur so ein paar Millionen Sonnen zusammensetzt. Die lokale Gruppe selber ist aber dann auch schon wieder in einem, wie nennt man dann, die nächste Stufe, in einem Galaxienhaufen zusammengefasst. Ist das dieser Virgo?
Das ist nochmal ein anderer. Das ist einer der nächsten Galaxienhaufen drum herum. Genau, die Galaxien verteilen sich im Universum auf großen Skalen, so ein bisschen wie so ein Schweizer Käse. The Cosmic Web nennt man das. So Knotenpunkte bestehen aus Galaxienhaufen. Da sind so 100 bis 1000 Galaxien in so einem Galaxienhaufen drin. Die sind alle verbunden mit Filamenten von Galaxien. Das sind längliche Brücken zwischen diesen ganzen Knotenpunkten, diesen Galaxienhaufen. Dazwischen gibt es die großen Löcher im Schweizer Käse, die nennt man Cosmic Voids, große Leeregebiete. Die Galaxien haben andere Eigenschaften, je nachdem, ob sie in so einem Galaxienhaufen leben, in so einem Filament oder in so einem Void sind. Auch das spielt eine Rolle. Und so sind eben auf ganz großen Skalen die Galaxien verteilt.
Von wie viel Galaxien weiß man denn jetzt? Also, ich meine, wie viel kann man denn sehen? Abgesehen von Schätzung. Drumherum sieht man mit dem Feldstecher, wenn man mit Hubble guckt, kann man ja sehr weit schauen. Da gibt es ja auch dieses berühmte Bild, wo Hubble mal sich gedacht hat, jetzt gucken wir uns mal keinen Stern an, sondern jetzt gucken wir mal irgendwo hin, wo nichts ist, in Anführungsstrichen. Und dann hat man dieses Nichts über zehn Tage beleuchtet. Und auf einmal hat man festgestellt, oh mein Gott, it's full of stars, überall Galaxien, Galaxien, Galaxien, wohin man schaut. Das Schwarz, das Nichts ist eigentlich voll. Von daher überrascht es vielleicht, wenn man jetzt hört, naja, aber es gibt eben auch wirklich Orte des Nichts.
Also das Nichts ist immer so ein bisschen relativ. Auch in diesem Volt gibt es Galaxien. Die sind dann meist ein bisschen anämisch. Aber da gibt es auch Galaxien. Ganz nichts gibt es wirklich nirgendwo. Es gibt immer, bei jedem Teil des Universums, gibt es Materie.
Ja, bei wie vielen Galaxien sind denn so kartografiert worden bisher?
Ja, 100.000. Also je nachdem, was man meint mit kartografiert.
Also man meint, das ist, man sieht sie.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt schaut, ist das nun eine Galaxie? Oder will man die Entfernung mit dabei haben, sind es 100.000. Das Sloan Digital Sky Survey ist ein so ein Projekt, wo man mit robotischen Teleskopen den Himmel automatisch, einen Teil des Himmels, eine Region des Himmels, automatisch, robotisch abgetastet hat, Entfernung bestimmt hat, das Licht analysiert, so bestimmt man die Entfernung, und die Galaxien kategorisiert hat, hat man 100.000 von Galaxien, in die man da rauskommt. Gleichzeitig gibt es im Radiobereich auch bestimmte Durchmusterungen des Himmels, die Galaxienkataloge produzieren. Und das ist so die Größenordnung von Galaxien, die man ungefähr kategorisiert hat.
Sodass man sagen kann, wenn wir schon in der Lage sind, hunderttausende Galaxien zu sehen, dann kann es sich nur um eine absurd viel größere Zahl von Galaxien handeln, die es tatsächlich gibt.
Die tatsächliche Zahl von Galaxien ist wahrscheinlich unendlich, weil der Raum unendlich groß ist.
Der Raum ist unendlich groß?
Der Raum ist unendlich groß. Nur können wir selbst, wenn wir perfekte Zählskope hätten, nicht den gesamten Raum sehen, weil das Universum nur endlich alt ist. Und das Licht seit Beginn des Universums nur eine gewisse Strecke zurücklegen kann.
Aber müsste es da nicht auch unendlich viel Licht geben, wenn es unendlich viele Galaxien und Sonnen gibt? Aber dann müsste es doch überall hell sein.
Ja, in unserem Bereich, der innerhalb unseres Horizonts gibt, gibt es in allem immer natürlich nur Endliches. Wir sehen sozusagen nur einen Teil. Genau. Der Horizont ist gesetzt von dem endlichen Alter des Universums. Das Universum ist ja nur 13,9 Milliarden Jahre alt und in der Zeit kann das Licht hier nur eine gewisse Strecke zurücklegen. Und weiter können wir nicht schauen. Die Lichtgeschwindigkeit setzt diesen Horizont. Dahinter könnten natürlich rein theoretisch... wissen wir natürlich nicht genau, was dahinter ist. Das wird ein Ikea sein, wer weiß. Aber alles spricht dafür, dass es natürlich dahinter weitergeht.
Aber wenn es unendlich groß ist, müsste es ja auch unendlich viel Materie geben. Das ist ja auch beim Urknall. Geht das überhaupt? Unendlich klingt es halt so wie unerschöpflich. Man würde ja meinen, dass es ein endliches Potenzial von Materie gegeben hat. Oder reden wir vielleicht von einer kosmologischen Struktur, die im Prinzip in der Lage ist, beliebig viel Materie zu produzieren?
Ja, das denkt man schon. Der Urknall ist nicht an einem Ort passiert. Auch in der Zeit des Urknalls war das Universum schon unendlich. Direkt nach dem Urknall war das Universum auch schon unendlich. Es war nicht eine Explosion wie so ein Knaller, wie so ein Böller, den man irgendwo hat. Und dass von dort alles passiert ist.
Sondern?
Das Universum ist eben, der ganze Raum ist entstanden mit dem Urknall und der war von Anfang an dann nach dem Urknall sofort unendlich. Und seitdem unendlich kann man ja noch größer machen. Es gibt ja unendlich viele Zahlen, rationale Zahlen zwischen 0 und 1. Unendlich viele, aber zwischen 0 und 2 gibt es doppelt so viele unendliche Zahlen.
Man macht sozusagen nochmal einfach mehr Kommastellen dazwischen. Trotzdem gibt es diese Ausdehnung. Und man kann diese Ausdehnung auch beobachten. Und man nimmt sie wahr durch diese Hintergrundstrahlung.
Genau. Also unter anderem. Ursprünglich hat man sie wahrgenommen, dass man die Fluchtgeschwindigkeiten der Galaxien gemessen hat. Hubble hat das in den 20er Jahren getan. Und dass das Universum sich ausdehnt, ist ja eher überraschend. Das ist ja so überraschend, dass ein Stern das ja auch nicht gut fand. Das Universum ausdehnt, das hätte eigentlich keiner so erwartet. Das hat dann Edwin Hubble gemessen, indem er gemessen hat die Verschiebung von Spektrallinien in diesen Galaxienspektren. Und dadurch kommt man darauf, dass alles sich von uns weg bewegt. Und dann kann man letztendlich darauf das Universum sich eben ausdehnt. Und alle Galaxien voneinander sich entfernen mit zunehmendem Alter des Universums. Und das ist die Ausdehnung des Universums. Da kam man dann auf den Urknall. Und eine besonders beeindruckende Bestätigung des Konzepts ist dieser Kostische Mikrowellenhintergrund. Weil man hat dann gesagt, wenn das Universum mit dem Urknall entstanden ist, und das so ist, dann muss es ja ein Überbleibsel sein, wie so ein Echo oder so ein Relikt. Also, wenn unsere Theorie so stimmt, müsste man das sehen, müsste man eine Strahlung sehen, die isotropisch ist, was aus allen Raumrichtungen gleich ist und die eine gewisse Temperatur hat von 3 Kelvin, die minus 270 Grad Strahlungskarakteristik hat. Und die hat man dann auch gemessen.
Aber es war nicht so gleichmäßig verteilt.
Am Anfang des Universums war das extremst gleichmäßig verteilt. So ein Teil in 100.000 was Universum, also glatte als Oberfläche des Tisches, die natürlich ihre Hörer jetzt hier nicht sehen, ist weil das Universum total glatt und gleichmäßig verteilt. Also ganz winzige kleine Flutportionen, Unreinheiten darauf. Wenn man sich das Universum im Mikrowellen anschaut, war das Universum smooth as you can imagine. Das war unfassbar glatt und man muss sehr viel Aufwand aufwenden, um diese Fluktuation, diese ganzen Unreinheiten überhaupt dann aufzuspüren. Und die Planck-Mission, von der du ja auch schon berichtet hast, ist die letzte Mission, die genau nach diesen Unreinheiten geschaut hat und die ganzen Charakteristiken dieser Unreinheiten. Denn diese ganzen Unreinheiten sind das, woraus wir und die ganze Struktur im Universum entstanden ist.
Die Unreinheit des Urknalls ist das, was wir sind.
Wenn es jetzt keine Unreinheit gäbe im Universum, also alles gleich wäre, beliebig bis auf so viele Nachkommastellen, wie man möchte, alles gleich wäre, dann wäre es im Universum ja nie was passiert.
Weil alles in Balance wäre.
Nur dadurch, dass es so Unreinheiten gibt, gibt es dann eine Region, die ein hunderttausendstel schwerer war als die Nachbarregion. Die fängt dann unter dem Einfluss der Schwerkraft an, sich zusammenzuziehen und dadurch das zu bilden, was heute unsere Galaxien sind, unsere Galaxienhaufen sind.
Das heißt, diese Unreinheit hat überhaupt erst Wechselwirkungen losgetreten, dass eine Region stärker war als die andere und damit ein asymmetrischer Einfluss stattfand. Der hat dann Strukturen herausgebildet. Die Struktur, die jetzt herausgebildet wurde im Verlauf von 13,8 Milliarden Jahren, die sich dieses ganze Universum, was man so schon perfekt angefangen hat, sich ausdehnt, bilden sich quasi diese ganzen Unreinheiten ab in Galaxien, die von Abermilliarden Sternen bewohnt werden, die im Prinzip auch Unregelmäßigkeiten sind, weil sie Gas zusammenklumpen, Planeten ausbilden und irgendwie von verrückten Podcastern umkreist werden. Und das macht sozusagen jetzt dieses Universum aus. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, dieses Bild des Schweizer Käses ist quasi eine sich aus dieser Entwicklung ableitende Struktur, wo man sagen kann, es gibt Orte der Verdickung, solche Knotenpunkte, die mit anderen Knotenpunkten verbunden sind durch diese Filamente, also durch so quasi so Kanäle und überall da sind Häufungen von Sternen und Galaxien zu finden. Aber dazwischen gibt es schon auch so Voids. Wie void sind die? Also wie leer sind diese leeren Bereiche? Sind die so leer, dass man sagt, da ist wirklich gar nichts? Oder kann man sich das gar nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendwo gar nicht ist?
Also wie wir eben schon bei den Größen gesehen haben, ist alles sehr relativ. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel sprechen von dem, also ich forsche unter anderem über das Gas zwischen den Galaxien, da reden wir dann oft über sehr dichte Regionen, aber diese dichteren Regionen sind dann doch dünner als das beste Vakuum, was man jemals in einer Vakuumpumpe hier in einem Labor auf der Erde erzeugen kann. Trotzdem, wenn man sich jetzt so einen Galaxienhaufen anschaut, mit seinen tausenden Galaxien drin, ist das ganze Gas zwischen den Galaxien, was dünner ist als das beste Vakuum, was man hier erzeugen kann, viel dünner als das beste Vakuum, was man hier erzeugen kann, ist das ganze, die Masse von dem Gas in dieser Phase, also in diesem intergalaktischen Zeug, ist viel mehr Masse als in allen Sternen zusammengenommen in dem ganzen Galaxienhaufen, weil der Galaxienhaufen so groß ist. Die meiste Masse in normaler Materie befindet sich eben in diesem dünner als Vakuum Zeug, in diesem Nichts. Das Nichts ist größer als alles andere. Deswegen ist es immer schwer zu sagen, was ist jetzt nicht, ist es jetzt schwer, ist es wenig, ist es nichts. Also es gibt natürlich keinen Raum im Universum, wo nichts ist. In jedem Kubikmeter sind Atome. Es gibt keinen Kubikmeter im Universum, wo jetzt nicht ein Atom oder ein Teilchen drin ist. Überall gibt es was. Ganz leer gibt es nichts. Es gibt auch überall irgendwo eine Galaxie in der Nähe. Und diese Galaxie ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner, ein bisschen schwächer und weiter auseinander, aber irgendwo gibt es auch immer eine Galaxie.
Okay, also das Nichts gibt es nicht, es gibt überall etwas, aber es ist so wenig, dass wir das sozusagen mit unseren irrischen Vorstellungen nur sehr schwer fassen können, weil wir noch nicht mal in der Lage wären, das nachzubauen. Wir könnten so ein Interstellaren- Kubikmeter quasi gar nicht herstellen.
Nein, das ist eben so ein bisschen das Interessante eben, warum man eben auch Astrophysik unter anderem, warum man Astrophysik macht, um eben auch zu lernen über Materiezustände, die man hier gar nicht erzeugen kann. Das gilt für das Zentrum der Sonne. Plasmen wie im Zentrum der Sonne kann man hier nicht herstellen. Man versucht das, wäre schön, wenn man das könnte. Und auch Materiezustände wie das Gas zwischen den Sternen oder zwischen den Galaxien kann man hier auch nicht herstellen. Und das gibt es viele Fragestellungen, was dann überhaupt mit solchen exotischen materielichen Zuständen passiert, was da passiert, was für Mechanismen da am Werk sind. Das ist auch ein Teil der Motivation, warum man diese Forschung macht. Man kann eben viele Sachen, die man da beobachtet, nicht in Laboratorien hier auf der Erde nachbauen, nachstellen. Und natürlich unser Menschliches, das ist ein bisschen das interessante an der Astronomie oder vielleicht das Faszinierende daran, ist, dass alle unsere menschlichen, von der Evolution uns gegebenen Wahrnehmungsgrenzen von was schwer ist, was weit ist, was heiß ist, alle natürlich da nicht gelten. Die Größen können wir uns eigentlich nicht vorstellen, auch wenn man jetzt Forscher ist auf dem Gebiet.
Wenn hier 20 Grad mehr Kelvin da draußen sind, dann drehen wir schon total durch und sind kurz vorm Verrecken, aber die Abermillionen von Graden, die in Sonnen erzeugt werden, sind beyond.
Ja, kann man eben sich nicht vorstellen, das sind unsere Gehirne nicht gemacht, das kann man eben nur mit der Sprache der Mathematik und mit irgendwie erzeugen, aber man kann sich nicht vorstellen, was so ein Megapartype ist. Man kann sich der Brücken zu bauen, aber die Vorstellung ist natürlich schwierig.
Jetzt muss ich noch mal einen Begriff aufgreifen, der schon fiel, nämlich die dunkle Materie. Es ist ja eine der Erkenntnisse der letzten, ich weiß nicht, 20 Jahre, dass das, was wir jetzt immer meinen, das, was wir sehen, dass das, was wir auch wahrnehmen, messen können, die Atome, die Materie, die uns umfliegt, offenbar nur einen geringen Teil dessen ausmacht, was in diesem Universum tatsächlich ist. Und die einzige Antwort, die es bisher gibt, ist, die ist halt irgendwie dunkel im Sinne von, wir können sie nicht sehen. Was hat es damit auch? Also woher weiß man das, dass es das gibt? Und was weiß man darüber, was es sein könnte?
Man weiß es schon seit einer ganzen Weile, dass es mehr Materie im Universum sein muss, als man denkt. Das weiß man schon seit den 20er Jahren. Fritz Zwicky war einer der ersten, der das herausgefunden hat, der sich den Chromagalaxienhaufen angeschaut hat und gesagt hat, also das Licht, was wir da alle sehen, das reicht nicht aus, um das Gebilde zusammenzuhalten. Dann hat man die Rotationskurven von Galaxien studiert, von Spiralgalaxien und hat gesehen, die Zentrifugalkraft müsste diese ganzen Sterne da rausreißen. Das tut es nicht. Da muss mehr Anziehung da sein. Und dann gab es dann Beweistrang nach Beweisstücke, wie in so einem Kriminalfall, das darauf hinweist, dass wir heute ganz sicher wissen, dass es so was wie dunkle Materie geben muss. Sonst würde sich diese ganzen Gebilde, dieser ganze Schweizer Käse, von dem wir gesprochen haben, diese Gebilde, die sich eben aus dieser Mini-Fluktuation des kosmischen Mikrowellenhintergrunds, oder das, was wir im kosmischen Mikrowellenhintergrund sehen, gebildet haben, hätte sich niemals gebildet. Deswegen muss es so was geben wie dunkle Materie. Und wir wissen mittlerweile, dass es nicht normale Materie sein kann. Es können nicht mehr Neutrinos sein, das schon das exotischste ist. Also gibt es irgendeinen Elementarteil, das wir noch nicht kennen.
Also warum weiß man das, dass es das nicht sein kann? Was ist das Ausschlusskriterium an der Stelle?
Wir wissen, dass aus der Elementverteilung des Universums, weil es gibt eine Theorie, die sehr, sehr genau ist, wie die Elemente im Universum verteilt sind, wie viel Wasserstoff, wie viel Helium es im Universum gibt. Und deswegen wissen wir, dass, weil wir das genau vorhersagen können, wie viel Wasserstoff, wie viel Helium es gibt, dass es eben kein bekanntes Teichchen sein kann, was da noch da sein könnte.
Woher weiß man denn diese Verteilung?
Diese Verteilung kann man ja nicht...
Wir sehen ja noch nicht mal alles.
Das stimmt, ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Aber wir können im Universum relativ genau vermessen an Orten, wo noch kein Stern irgendwas prozessiert hat, was die ursprüngliche Elementverteilung ist. Weil die einzige Möglichkeit, von der ursprünglichen Elementverteilung zu anderen Elementverteilungen zu kommen, ist Kernfusion in Sterninnere. Und es gibt Möglichkeiten, wie man Sachen, die sagen wir mal unverpestet sind durch Sternabfälle, die jungfräuliche Teile des Universums, die man vermessen kann. Da weiß man genau, was der Anteil von Helium ist.
Ach so, man hat sich sozusagen solche Voids angeschaut und gesagt, was ist denn da? Aber wenn da nur irgendwie fünf Atome pro Quadratmeter rumhängen, kann man das überhaupt. Also ausreichend beobachten?
Absolut, weil es eben alles immer so groß sind. So das Galaxienhaufen, das eben nur so ein Teilchen pro Kubikzentimeter hat, wirklich extrem dünne Regionen, die beobachten man mit Röntgensatelliten zum Beispiel. Die sind extrem hell, extrem helle Quellen. Die sind so groß.
Weil es einfach so viele Kubikzentimeter sind?
Ja, das schlägt das. Die dünne wird geschlagen von der größte. Dadurch sind diese Dinger hell.
Und diese schaut man sich an und sieht, das ist jetzt quasi die natürliche Verteilung des Urmaterials, was im Wesentlichen nur Wasserstoff und Helium ist. Daraus kann man dann hochrechnen, wenn das so die natürliche Verteilung ist, dann müsste es so und so viel geben. Der Rest kann sich nur aus Sternen heraus gebildet haben, also es ist im Prinzip nicht mehr Masse, sondern nur in anderer Form. Und das, was man jetzt zusammenrechnet, kann nicht erklären, wie Galaxien zusammenhalten, kann nicht erklären, wie Galaxien Cluster zusammenhalten und auch keine Super-Cluster etc. Also irgendwas anderes muss noch da sein, auch wenn man es nicht sieht. Und was ist das dann?
Das ist irgendein unbekanntes Teilchen und man weiß nicht, was es ist.
Ein Teilchen, was man nicht messen kann, weil es noch nicht vorbei gekommen ist oder weil es irgendwelche Eigenschaften hat, die sich uns komplett entziehen.
Durch uns strömen diese Teilchen gerade in enormer Menge. Wir wechseln wirklich mit uns nun in diesem Moment. Aber die nehmen wir nicht wahr. Was nicht besonders ist, weil Neutrinos machen das genauso. Die misst man und die kennt man. Und das Teilchen wenig wechselwirken, das ist nichts besonderes. Es ist ein Teilchen, das wir nicht kennen. Das verstört mich eigentlich nicht so. Ich verstehe nie immer so ganz, wo die Leute denken, das kann doch gar nicht sein, als ob es gegeben sein müsste, dass wir unsere Teilchen kennen. Es ist eigentlich schon total oft vorgekommen, dass die Physiker gesagt haben, Moment mal, hier ist irgendwas faul. Es muss noch ein anderes Teilchen geben. Also vor zwei, drei Tagen hat sich die Entdeckung des Neptunes zum 150. Mal gejährt oder so. Und auch der Neptun wurde vorhergesagt, weil es in der Bahn von Uranus Probleme gab, Störungen gab. Also haben wir gesagt, da muss es noch was anderes geben. Und dann hat die LW, dann haben wir Couch Adams und wie heißt der Franzose nochmal? Dann berechnet, wo der sein musste. Und also da hat man ein Teilchen genommen. Bei dem Neutron war es so, im Atomkern hat man gesagt, na gut, die ganzen Protonen, die da alle positiv geladen sind, die stoßen sich da ab, da muss es doch noch ein anderes Teilchen geben im Atomkern. Da wurde das Neutron postuliert von irgendwelchen Physikern. Das hat dann James Chadwick auch ein paar Jahre später dann gefunden. Beim Neutrino, was Wolfgang Pauli gesagt hat, unsere Naturgesetze im Wetterzerfall, das stimmt nicht. Entweder müssen wir das Naturgesetz ändern oder da muss es noch ein Teilchen geben, was wir nicht sehen. Das hat er Neutrino genannt. Das ist jetzt nur noch ein besonderes fieses Teilchen. Das hat man eine ganze Weile gebraucht. Das hat man in den 15er Jahren entdeckt, in den USA, bei so Kernreaktoren. Das selbe passiert eben in der Astronomie auch. Man hat gesagt, das stimmt nicht. Irgendwas stimmt da nicht. Entweder können wir das Naturgesetz ändern, also die Gravitation ändern, oder das Gravitationsgesetz ändern, oder da müssen es noch andere Teilchen sein. Das Naturgesetz ändern scheint nicht gut zu funktionieren. Das hat man auch lange Zeit probiert. Das haben Leute probiert, ob jetzt auf großen Skalen vielleicht die Relativitätstheorie nicht mehr stimmt, wo Gravitation irgendwie andere Eigenschaften hat, aber das glaube ich nicht. Dazu müsste es schon sehr komisch sein, wenn das so sein sollte. Deswegen ist eigentlich die beste Erklärung, dass es einfach irgendein Teilchen gibt, das was es noch nicht gibt, und das wechselt eben schwach mit anderer Materie. Deswegen ist das schwer zu finden. Das versucht man gerade zu finden am Large Hadron Collider. Man versucht es, Boar herzustellen. Was ich so höre von den Kollegen in der Teilchenphysik, das sieht im Moment nicht so toll aus. Sie hatten die große Hoffnung, dass sie es vielleicht finden würden, aber irgendwie haben sie es noch nicht gefunden. Da schießt man ja dann Protonen zusammen und dann sucht man auch nach Ereignissen, wo dann eben was erzeugt wird und auf der anderen Seite eben nichts erzeugt wird. Also, dass irgendwas fehlt, dass irgendwas verschwindet in diesen dunklen Materie, die man sucht. Jetzt hätte man irgendwo ein Loch da drin. Das ist jetzt die große Hoffnung, dass man es findet. Das dauert eben schon relativ frustrierend lang, aber so ist das eben manchmal, dass es eben lange dauert. Beim Neutrino hat es auch einige Jahrzehnte gedauert, bis man es dann wirklich gefunden hat. Und jetzt sitzt man auch schon einige Jahrzehnte daran nach der dunklen Materie. Es könnte auch noch sein, dass es eine ganze Weile dauert.
Weil man ja eigentlich gar nicht weiß, woraus es eben besteht, weiß man ja vielleicht auch gar nicht, auf welche Art und Weise man es überhaupt direktieren kann.
Genau, man weiß ja nicht, wie man macht davon. Masse heißt auch Energie. Also man weiß ja gar nicht, wie hoch man, wie stark man sein Beschleuniger bauen soll, um es eben genau zu finden. Das war anders bei dem Higgs-Teilchen. Bei dem Higgs-Teilchen hatte man recht gute Hinweise darauf, wo das ungefähr sein müsste. Deswegen wusste man im Grunde, dass wenn man diesen Large Hadron Collider baut, mit seiner bestimmten Power, hat man gewissen Pausen, da muss da sein. Das wusste man relativ genau. Jetzt bei der dicken Materie kann es einfach sein, die suchen jetzt noch lange, die werden das Ding noch ein paar Mal upgraden, bis es dann eine gewisse Energie hat, die maximale Energie, die sie da erzeugen können. Und dann kann es sein, dass die sagen, ja gut, muss noch schwerer sein.
Noch schwerer ist es?
Ja, je höher die Energie ist, umso schwerere Teile kann man dann in den Kollisionen erzeugen, weil die Energie in Masse umgewandelt wird. Okay, und wenn das dann halt so schwer ist? Dann ist es halt schwerer als das, was zufälligerweise dort, nicht zufälligerweise, aber was dort jetzt genau untersucht wird. Und das kann halt sein. Und dann ist es natürlich ein bisschen frustrierend. Aber es gibt auch andere Arten, natürlich nach diesen Teilchen zu suchen. Man sucht ja in großen unterirdischen Laboratorien auch. Da versucht man Teilchen, diese dunklen Materiateilchen, die durch und durch strömen, auch zu entdecken. Wenn sie dann gegen einen Atom knallen, dass man die Schwingung von diesem Atom misst. Da gibt es um die Welt verteilt verschiedene Laboratorien, die das machen. Auch die denke ich mir, wenn wir das irgendwann finden.
Irgendwann. Aber man weiß, kann man damit rechnen? Man weiß schon, was die Summe davon ist. Man weiß nur nicht, aus wie viel Teilchen es sich zusammensetzt.
Man weiß weder, wie schwer die Teilchen sind, auch die Wirkungsquerschnitte nicht. Das ist schon ein bisschen Fischen im Trüben. Und die Theorien sind auch noch völlig unterschiedlich. Was es da für Teilchen gibt. Es gibt, wie manche sagen, es sind so relativ massive Teilchen, die aus irgendwie supersymmetrischen Theorien kommen. Im Bereich von GeV, Gegelektronenvolt, also mehrere Massen von Protonen und Höher. Hunderte GeV vielleicht. Das nennt man dann schwere Teilchen. Jetzt ist man wieder bei der Relativität, was man schwer und nicht schwer bezeichnet. Oder manche Leute sagen, das sind ganz, ganz kleine Teilchen, Aktionen. Sehr, sehr leichte Teilchen zum Beispiel. Und da gibt es einen ganzen Zoo von Theorien, die zu jeder Masse irgendeine Vorhersage haben. Darum ist es ja interessant, darum ist es ja spannend. Wenn man das alles wüsste, wäre es ja keine wirkliche Forschung. Das wäre langweilig. Langweilig. Also ist es in gewisser Weise faszinierend, dass man eben den größten Teil des Universums nicht versteht.
Es gibt da noch so einen anderen dunklen Kandidaten. Die Energie, die Dunkle. Hat die was damit zu tun, oder ist das eine ganz andere Abteilung?
Nein, die ist eigentlich was Unabhängiges davon. Die hat nur einen ähnlichen Namen, das man auch Dunkel genannt hat, was auch ein blöder Name ist.
Dunkle ist sozusagen alles, was man nicht weiß.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein blöder Name. Viele Kollegen von mir regen sich auch darüber auf, was ein blöder Name ist. Die hat man erst 1995, glaube ich, entdeckt. Das ist eigentlich nur noch verrückter als dunkle Materie. Darüber weiß man wirklich fast gar nichts.
Aber was ist denn der Grund, dass man dafür diesen Namen überhaupt geschaffen hat?
Man sieht eben, dass das Universum, dass die Ausdehnung des Universums sich beschleunigt, anstelle abzunehmen. Man würde denken, die wird abnehmen, weil alles sich hier anzieht im Universum. Also am Anfang stiebt alles auseinander und die Anziehung untereinander muss eigentlich dazu führen, dass es eher abgebremst wird, als dass es irgendwie zunimmt. Aber man beobacht das Gegenteil. Da hat man gesagt, da muss es irgendwas geben, was auseinander treibt, die ganzen Galaxien im Universum.
Das heißt, das Universum hört nicht auf, sich auszudehnen. Es dehnt sich immer schneller aus, als es am Anfang getan hat.
Ja, also noch nicht. Am Anfang hat es sich ganz schnell ausgedehnt. Dann ist es immer langsamer geworden. Und dann sind wir jetzt in einem Zeitpunkt an, wo es anfängt wieder zuzunehmen, die Ausdehnung. Wir sehen uns jetzt nicht schneller aus als früher. Das hat sich schon abgenommen. Diesen Effekt hätten wir jetzt auch vor ein paar Milliarden Jahren wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht entdeckt, weil es erst langsam diese dunkle Energie anfängt, Wirkung zu zeigen.
Das ist ein Phänomen, der jetzt gerade...
Das ist ein Incoming.
Das ist erst eine Milliarde Jahre her.
Das muss erst in gewisser Raum eingenommen werden, bevor dieser Effekt bestbar wird.
Aber wenn das nicht linear war, diese Ausdehnung, könnte es doch auch sein, dass es dann irgendwann auch wieder erschwächelt.
Ja.
Oder ist das nicht vorstellbar? Aber wenn es jetzt so weitergeht, dehnt sich das Universum immer schneller aus. Das heißt ja, dass alle Sterne, die wir sehen, also vor allem die anderen Galaxien, also das, was wir überhaupt sehen, sich immer weiter von uns entfernt. Und das würde ja dann bedeuten, dass wir sie irgendwann gar nicht mehr sehen. Genau. Weil sie so weit weg sind, dass sie sich von uns schneller entfernen, als das Licht reisen kann.
Die verlassen irgendwann unseren Horizont.
Das heißt, die Ausdehnung des Raums ist etwas, was von der eigentlichen Bewegung im Raum vollkommen entkoppelt ist. Der Raum hat ganz eigene Parameter und ganz eigene Vorstellungen von Geschwindigkeit in dem Sinne, als das, was innerhalb des Raums selbst passiert.
Genau. Das ist im Grunde die Revolution der Relativitätstheorie. Dass eben dieser Raum eigene Eigenschaften hat. Die Raumzeit eigene Eigenschaften hat.
Das heißt, der Raum wird einfach so weit gedehnt, dass selbst das Licht dann irgendwann nicht mehr mithalten kann.
Genau.
Dann wird es ja zappenduster.
Dann wird es dann zappenduster, ja. Also wenn dann, sagen wir mal, in so einer fernen Zukunft dann in so einer Galaxie, die dann ganz allein ist, alle anderen Galaxien sind außerhalb des Horizonts, wenn dann eine Zivilisation anfängt, sie dort zu entstehen, die können z.B. gar keine Kosmologie machen. Die denken halt, sie leben in dem Universum, da gibt es nur eine Galaxie drin und sonst nichts. Die haben keine Ahnung, was es alles gab und was hinter ihrem Horizont ist.
So könnte es uns ja im Prinzip auch schon gegangen sein.
So ist es uns wahrscheinlich irgendwie gegangen.
Irgendwas haben wir verpasst.
Wir haben bestimmt irgendwas verpasst. Es gibt vielleicht keine Möglichkeit, das zu sehen. Man weiß, was auf anderen Dimensionen, die kollabiert sind, passiert ist.
Aber die gute Nachricht ist, bevor es wirklich schwarz wird, ist unsere Sonne wahrscheinlich durchgerast.
Genau, das hat mit uns nichts zu tun.
Ich finde diese Dimensionen irgendwie enorm. Was ich auch gehört habe, stimmt das eigentlich, dass wenn, es gibt ja die seltenen Fälle, also selten, das ist auch relativ im Universum, was heißt schon selten, es gibt so viel von allen, dass es dann doch wieder relativ oft stattfindet, aber es ist jetzt kein alltägliches Phänomen, dass dann Galaxien auch schon mal mit anderen Galaxien zusammentreffen, also sich quasi ineinander hineinschieben. Stimmt es, dass wenn das passiert, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dann wirklich auch Unfälle passieren, also Sondern aufeinandertreffen, verhältnismäßig gering ist?
Genau, das passiert dann fast nie. Weil der Raum zwischen den Galaxien so viel ist. Also wenn man sich das mal vorstellt, wenn man jetzt das Universum so schrumpfen würde, dass die Sonne nur noch so groß ist wie eine Orange. Wie schätzte, wie weit dann der nächste Stern, Proxima Centauri, wo dann Proxima Centauri wäre?
Also die 50 Jahre?
Ohne zu rechnen, ich traue dir zu, ich weiß, dass du das ausrechnen könntest, aber einfach nur mal so geschätzt. Außer der Menge.
Weiß nicht, so 10.000 Kilometer?
Das ist gut geschätzt. Die meisten Leute sagen, dann wäre der nächste Stern irgendwie in Dalem oder so, oder in Hamburg vielleicht noch. Der nächste Stern wäre dann in Moskau, also so grafisch etwas weniger, ein paar tausend Kilometer entfernt. Da hat man eben diese ganze Ansammlung von Orangen. Der nächste Orange ist in Moskau. Da fliegen dann viele durcheinander durch.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich da zwei Orangen treffen, ist relativ übersichtlich.
Also Galaxien kollidieren relativ oft, aber Sterne relativ selten.
Und dann verwirbeln die sozusagen ineinander mehr.
Genau, jede Galaxie ist das Produkt, das wir heute sehen, Produkt von einer ganzen Reihe von Kollisionen. Und das versucht man ja auch mit Gaia herauszufinden. Man versucht da galaktische Archäologie zu betreiben. Man weiß, dass verschiedene Komponenten der Milchstraße ursprünglich mal andere Galaxien waren. Und nur durch diese Kollision ist unsere Milchstraße so groß geworden, so gewachsen, und ist diese Milchstraße, die es jetzt gibt, und es gibt verschiedene Komponenten in der Milchstraße. Das weiß man unter anderem durch Altersbestimmungen, Bestimmungen der chemikalischen Zusammensetzung der Sterne, dass die andere Vorgänger hatten, dass die andere Historien hatten. Dass man dadurch sagt, unsere Galaxie besteht eigentlich aus mehreren Galaxien, die irgendwann verschmolzen sind. Und das passiert eben die ganze Zeit. Das ist im frühen Universum öfters passiert als heute, und wie es in Zukunft passieren wird, wird es im frühen Universum eben dichter. Die Dichte von Galaxien, der mittlere Abstand zwischen den Galaxien war früher kleiner.
Zum Schluss vielleicht nochmal die Frage, was sind denn so die Missionen und Projekte, Teleskope, andere Beobachtungen, von denen man sich jetzt so die nächsten großen Erkenntnisse und Auflösungen von bestimmten Fragestellungen verspricht?
Ja, die Astronomie hat ja leider Gott sei Dank auch eben so ein Problem, dass sie so groß gewachsen ist, dass die Geräte, wenn man jetzt über Hardware redet, was man jetzt braucht, was für Entdeckungsmaschinen man braucht, um jetzt die nächsten großen Fragen zu erzeugen, dass man jetzt mittlerweile leider in solchen Sphären ist, dass die Maschinen anfangen sehr sehr teuer zu werden und sehr sehr groß zu werden. Dass man so eine richtige Großforschungslandschaft braucht, so wie das in der Teilchenphysik ja auch so ist. Wenig Teilchenphysik geschieht mittlerweile noch in Labors. Das passiert heute nur an supranationalen Riesendingern, die Milliarden von Euro kosten. Und in der Astronomie wird es teilweise zumindest auch so. Nicht nur, Gott sei Dank, aber schon ist dieser Trend da. Und da gibt es jetzt in Zukunft eben auf der Erde das ELT, das Extremely Large Telescope, der Europäer, die Amerikaner, versuchen ein ähnliches Projekt hochzuziehen. Das ist ein Teleskop, das von der europäischen Südstandwart, der ESO gebaut wird in Chile. Ein Teleskop der 40-Meter-Klasse. Und das hat eben eine Reihe von Zielen. Eins ist bestimmt die Beobachtung von Exoplaneten, Suche nach Leben, Suche nach Exoplaneten, aber auch Kosmologie und die Bestimmung der Eigenschaften der dunklen Energie. Dann im Radiobereich, die nächste Entdeckungsmaschine, das Square Kilometer Array, ein Radioteleskop. Dieses LOFAR-Teleskop, über das wir gesprochen haben, ist in einem gewissen Sinne das Vorläuferprojekt von diesem Projekt in Australien und Südafrika. Das wird im Grunde jede Galaxie des Universums, die wir überhaupt sehen können, sehen. Über eine Million Galaxien vermessen. Auch eine Gravitationswelle suchen, das frühe Universum erforschen. Auch eine riesen Entdeckungsmaschine, ein riesen Technologieprojekt. Es produziert im Jahr mehr Daten, als das gesamte Internet zusammen hat. Also ein super Projekt. Das sind so die beiden auf der Erde riesen Projekte. Dafür gibt es natürlich auch viele andere Projekte, die auch sehr, sehr wichtig sind. Die beiden sind nur so die größten vielleicht, die da herausstechen. Und dann gibt es Weltraummissionen. Auch die werden immer teurer, meistens. Mehr oder weniger. Im Röntgenbereich gibt es Athena bald. Die großen Missionen, die es da gibt. Es gibt es die Nachfolge des Hubble Teleskops, das James Webb Space Telescope. Das geht auch, das wird hier gerade zusammengebaut. Das kann man live mit Webcams auch verfolgen, teilweise. Das ist auch ein Unverrottbereich, ist auch ein wahndienstliches Projekt. Auch viele Milliarden Dollar, die der Bauer allein gekostet hat. Das sind so große Missionen, die jetzt für den extragalaktischen Bereich wichtig sind. Es gibt natürlich ganz plantaren Missionen, zu denen ich jetzt nichts sage, bei denen ich mich jetzt noch nicht so gut auskenne.
Wenn man sich anschaut, was das Hubble Space Telescope schon für einen Erkenntnisgewinn gebracht hat, und der war ja enorm, und ich denke, er hat auch bei Weipen alles übererfüllt, was man vorher, glaube ich, so hat hoffen können, insbesondere nachdem das Ding erst mal halb blind war. Weil es oben war und nur die Reparatur eigentlich erst in diesen Modus gebracht werden konnte, in dem es diese großartigen Bilder produziert. Könnten natürlich diese neuen Teleskope nochmal ganz neue Einblicke bieten, die wir uns vielleicht teilweise auch noch gar nicht so richtig vorstellen können. Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit hier zu Galaxien und unserem Kosmos. Das war jetzt mal der Blick ins große Ganze und das eine oder andere, was jetzt hier auch in dieser Sendung aufgegriffen wurde. Wenn wir sicherlich hier bei Raumzeit auch nochmal näher behandeln, aber das machen wir heute nicht alles, sondern irgendwann. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.